Donald Trump has pleaded not guilty and
waived his right to appear in court
that's the gist of that story we'll see
what the elements are moving forward
we'll talk a little bit about it but the
big news now is that proud boys are
being sentenced and Joe Biggs just got
sentenced to 17 years already on top of
the two and a half years he's already
been in prison and the reason this is so
shocking was a couple reasons one far
left extremists who burned down police
stations get less time they get direct
support from Democrats they win millions
of dollars in lawsuits but if you are a
right-winger like Joe Biggs and you tear
down a fence they got you now there's
tons of people posting photos from the
occupations the autonomous zones far
left extremists firebombing Federal
buildings and uh where are the criminal
charges for any of these people and the
ones that have got caught like the guy
in Minneapolis burning on the police
station four years
something doesn't make sense here's the
other component of the story The Judge
actually told him if you've got a
problem with an election then you can
speak out make phone calls file lawsuits
contact election officials but you can't
get violent
that's funny Donald Trump is being
criminally charged his lawyers are being
criminally charged members of the Trump
Administration have been criminally
charged for literally speaking out
filing lawsuits and contacting election
officials in fact
they've actually criminally charged the
election officials over this
so the system May in fact be quite a bit
broken we'll talk about that plus a
bunch of other political stories it's
getting interesting out there we've got
a Ron uh Rhonda Santos Super PAC
shutting down another larger back sising
door knocking operations and this is uh
has many people wondering what's to come
for the tennis campaign before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you tonight at 10 pm you don't want
to miss it as members you can actually
submit questions and potentially call
into the show to talk to us and our
guests we do five callers about five
every night and uh it could be you but
you have to sign up for at least six
months or sign up today at the 25 per
month level if you sign up right now
you'll have an opportunity to enter the
Discord submit your questions and it's a
good fun but also you'll notice Tim
guest.com this button right here it says
timcast IRL X Miami that's right we have
666 tickets remaining they're going fast
this went live just about a week ago and
we've sold just around 170
five tickets so uh they're starting to
pick up steam but uh we'll see get them
while you still can because we will
likely sell out the event as October 6th
from 6 p.m to 10 30 p.m we've got
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
gates with uh me lukerkowski and Ian
cross and of course it's going to be a
very fun show we got a pre-show we got
an after show and we really hope to see
you down there in Miami so again
timcast.com don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends because
word of mouth is is really how we've
gotten to the point where we are just
the only marketing we've really done is
those Times Square ads which I don't
actually know if those translate to
people actually watching a show is more
like a Prestige thing like aha we've
done it but in terms of people watching
the show it's because you guys posted on
Twitter Facebook wherever you can and uh
and help support the show and also a lot
of people have been posting clips from
the show and getting paid on on X and
for that I say please do that please
absolutely do that we've had a bunch of
people be like oh I made a couple
hundred bucks this month I was just
posting clips from Tim cast now I'm like
yes please do more that means we get
free advertising and you all get paid
I'm totally fine with that have fun
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is Adam Coleman
thank you for having me um who are you
I'm Adam Coleman I'm the founder of
wrong sweet publishing which is an
outlet where we advocate for people to
speak freely submit articles especially
opinion articles we just got into
journalism as well I'm also the author
of the book behind me black victim and
the black Victor which talks about race
but other important things like family
is really important these days
especially
um and I'm also the columnist for human
events and a frequent contributor to the
New York Post right on well thanks for
hanging out should be fun thank you
Hannah Clara bremelo's hanging out hey
I'm Hannah Claire I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm happy to be back and I'm
excited for this conversation and here
too of course hi everyone Ian Crossland
get your Casper if you haven't been to
castbrew.com yet tonight uh check it out
and get yourself a bag I had some of
that uh jeez which one was it yesterday
it was the uh not appellation Knights
game Roberto Jr no no stand your ground
it was stand your grounds we shot we
were shooting another commercial and
that was our prop coffee and man it is
good the rise with Roberto Jr is the
best selling wow yeah and it's like well
we got to sell the other coffee but
everybody wants the Roberto Jr probably
because he's on the back I'm pulling for
pumpkin spice so don't let me down
there's Mr Bogus he doesn't have the
pole that Roberto Jr has rest in peace
yeah bogus blend yeah we've got Kellen
pressing the buttons that's right
another day with me uh pushing buttons
uh my name is Kellen and I think I feel
like coffee is something that a lot of
people buy when it gets cold right it's
so hot when the dog days of summer right
now once it gets cold that Mr bocus
pumpkin spice I know it's going to take
off we beat Starbucks to the punch
seriously we got the Mr boca's pumpkin
spice experience so good right I gotta
have it forever yeah you got to get it
now before anyone else otherwise well
let's uh let's talk about news instead
of coffee hello uh let's uh let's just
jump into the first story Here We Go
From The Daily Mail former proud boys
leader Joe Biggs sobs during sentencing
as he given 17 years in prison over
January 6 after begging Court not to
separate him from his daughter and
cancer-stricken mom Biggs Ethan Nordeen
Zachary Rail and Enrique Taria were all
found guilty of the charges after they
broke into the capital following 2020
election full stop fake news Enrique
tario is actually not there
so uh yeah his charges I don't believe
anything to do with him he was arrested
beforehand and barred from the city
tario was not there so uh you gotta you
gotta correct that one Daily Mail
the judge ruled Biggs was qualified for
a terrorism sentencing enhancement big
sentence is one of the harshest handed
out in capital Riot cases only behind
the 18-year sentence for Oath Keepers
founder Stuart Rhodes
here's where it gets interesting so this
is Joe Biggs many of you may know him he
worked for uh Infowars he said I know
that I have to be punished I understand
but he added please give me the chance I
beg you to take my daughter to school
and pick her up I wanted to see what
would happen my curiosity got the best
of me I am not a terrorist I'm one of
the nicest people in the world judge
Timothy Kelly wasn't having it as he
said Americans are the Envy of the world
and U.S elections must be respected
telling Biggs you did play a role in
riling up the crowd if you don't like
how an election is being conducted you
can speak out call write or meet with
election officials you can engage in
peaceful protest file a lawsuit that
right there is why I think we absolutely
have to talk about this story because
that judge lied or he's really dumb
maybe both uh if you peacefully protest
like the people who were walking around
the other side of the building
they're going to arrest you anyway if
you say sit in front of an abortion
clinic they're going to try to give you
11 years in prison because you
peacefully protested how about this if
you speak out on Twitter they'll claim
it's part of a criminal conspiracy if
you make a phone call part of a criminal
conspiracy write or meet with election
officials not only are they charging
Donald Trump his staff and legal team
for doing these things they've even
criminally charged the election
officials that they met with
so this is insanity 17 years why what
did he do he tore a fence down should he
have done it no should he have been
punished or prosecuted or whatever yeah
two and a half years maybe a little
harsh for tearing down a fence you take
a look at what what happened with the
far left extremists BLM or otherwise
nothing
so this is particularly extreme we have
some commentary here Matt Walsh says a
man just got 17 years in prison for
tearing down a fence on January 6.
meanwhile a guy responsible for burning
an entire police station to the ground
during the BLM riots got only four years
no sane person thinks this is justice
but we do not live in a sane world it is
an insane world and of course Marjorie
Taylor green has come out saying proud
boys organizer Joseph big sentence to 17
years by U.S District Judge Timothy
Kelly how many violent BLM writers are
serving 17 years especially after
rotting in jail for the past two years
j6ers need to be pardoned they've been
persecuted enough
I have um
you know this this is the kind of thing
that gives me a sinking feeling because
what I what I did following the story is
I went to look at a few forums to see
what the sentiment was among Trump
supporters and uh fans of Joe Biggs and
uh
yeah it's getting scary out there
because the response from these people
is terrifyingly as I've predicted the
view that the government is illegitimate
law enforcement doesn't exist and the
perception among those who support
Donald Trump is increasingly becoming
and for many already is that these law
enforcement officers are no different
than a guy in a clown costume that if a
person walks up to you wearing a set of
clothes it doesn't mean anything they're
now saying that this is soviet-style
Communist Revolution this is what was
happening in the Spanish Civil War and
if this escalates and likely will
because the far left will not stop
they're going insane they they're I
don't know if they're a zombie horde
setting fired everything around them
just screeching the top of their lungs
or it's intentional but
you don't want to know who's at fault
for the continuous drive in this country
it's not Joe Biggs it's it's it's this
judge 17 years that's going to freak
people out and not the way they think
now here's here's what I want to add
before we just jump into the full
conversation the reason why they gave
him 17 years it has nothing to do with
who Joe Biggs is or what he did it's
because of the mob phenomenon and they
want everyone to know that they will
throw the book at you and the hammer if
you engage in any kind of mob mentality
phenomenon that is to say
often what we see in these riots with
far left you have a mob of people
walking around clueless one guy will
walk up to a door at a store and jiggle
the handle and then run away another guy
will run up within a split second as
he's running away and grab the handle
and pull the door open
someone else will see the door being
opened and they'll peek their head in
someone behind him will shove him in
then people see people going in the
building and they all start rushing the
building there was no immediate action
where an individual thought to
themselves we should storm this building
and that's what happens with Joe Bix
he's just there he has no idea what's
going on despite the fact that they say
that there's Communications by the proud
boys yeah they were saying like what are
we doing what's going on he's there
people start taking action and he goes
along with it so they're basically
setting an example we don't care who you
are we don't care what you've done if
you are in the mob you're going down and
that's why the people who did not get
violent and had no idea was happening in
the side of the building are being
criminally charged the courts have
literally told them because you were
part of a mob you are going to prison I
with Joe Biggs uh one of those tweets is
the first tweet you pulled up said that
he's getting so Matt Walsh 17 years for
tearing down a fence but Kellen you
mentioned before the show he was also
screaming a bear kid he was also yelling
to people to go in and to do stuff no no
I just said they were proud like there's
there's videos of him saying we just we
just did it yeah we were just in there
like heck yeah they were how
and the video in the court and the trial
was someone walking out to him being
like we just got in the capital what do
you think and he goes awesome okay so
he's just celebrating I mean there's
also video of Zachary reel who's also
sentenced today he's getting 15 years
and he was also convicted of suspicious
conspiracy during this three-month trial
uh of him saying don't go into the
capitol don't go in there and they're
like irrelevant to us you have to go in
because later you threw something at a
police officer I mean there are things
where I can agree like it was don't
throw stuff at cops don't throw
something out of hand on the other hand
both of these men have young children
and you're locking them up to prove your
political Point yeah and that's pretty
sick it's it's I the metaphor I think is
like if a bully attacks another kid in
school everyone's like oh God you want
the bully to lose so the kid somehow
fights back and he beats the bully and
he knocks the bully down then everyone's
like Yay but if the kid starts stomping
on the bully's face and smashing his
skull people will run over and grab the
kid and pull him off this the government
has gone too far by hitting these guys
with 17 years they're now now smashing
the skull of the guy that there it's
unnecessary a bit brutal but I agree
extremely brutal what they're doing and
it's going to cause massive anti it
couldn't cause sentiment that people are
going to start to hate the victim now
this is right this is even even the
krakensteins are like we think this is a
little bit harsh yeah and I'm like wow
well and Kelly is the second judge that
has said something to the effect of like
because of you we no longer have stable
elections and because it's this judge's
fault I I hope everybody make like you
understand that
you know to to throw a point to Ian who
often talks about pardoning your enemies
now I don't completely agree with
pardoning the worst war criminals of Our
Generation but there is something to be
said of the Chinese finger trap problem
in that the harder you pull the worse
you make it and this is the judge being
the the judge may as well have looked
into the camera for the for NBC News and
CNN and said that his goal is to destroy
this country because the sentiment among
those who support Trump is that they are
coming for you they are coming for your
families they are they're using violence
they are like the the sentiment is not
well Justice was served
it's it's done the exact opposite this
is radicalizing people because the
sentence is psychotic right I was
thinking uh the the sentencing disparity
that Matt Walsh brought up could that be
the difference between prosecution and a
federal uh with a federal judge versus
like the really relaxed uh persecution
or prosecution that's happening for
different states in the different cities
perhaps but that but to the moral
question it doesn't really matter all
that much right right obviously we know
that the feds can be more harsh they
tend to win all of their cases the ones
they choose but it's just when you look
at these on the surface of what they are
obviously we can say bro if you're gonna
get in into a fight with FEDS You're
Gonna Lose hands down but 17 years for
knocking down a a barrier I mean it was
one of those like little metal barriers
yeah so it's not good you shouldn't do
it and I think you'd go to jail for it
but you'd think someone would get like
six seven months in jail for something
like that and I feel like I have to
maybe not even there two months I have
to point out that the justice department
asked for 33 years in prison and they
asked for 27 for Zachary reveals I mean
this is basically sort of half of what
they wanted and it's still in my opinion
way too much for what happened right and
the one thing I want to bring up is the
uh you remember the the case where the
New York City lawyers during the 2020
protests uh they were caught with with
the mall tough cocktails they got pretty
good sentencing from it so they weren't
given lenient sentencing not saying that
this isn't harsh but I think it's been
I think the feds are making an example
quite clearly
um and it's it's unjustified
um and like you said it's radicalizing
people as well so they're not they're
making an example while at the same time
radicalizing people which could possibly
create the same circumstance that we
ended up before and and I don't think
they're they care much about that like
they're thinking that step ahead but I
think for us who are just analyzing
things that seems like a plausible thing
that could happen
um and God forbid like one of these
indictments go through with with Trump
that uh to be honest I'm not a lawyer
but just looking at the different
indictments they don't make much sense
to me I I think that uh biggest lawyer
should file an appeal on the grounds
that the judge advocated for criminal
activity that the judge attempted to
incite the uh the defendant and his
associates and those listening to commit
crimes and incitement to commit a crime
is a crime in and of itself so I believe
this judge should be impeached he should
be removed and criminally charged for
the crime of advocating and inciting
others to engage in an elected election
interference and Sedition conspiracy
because he outright said if you don't
like how the election's been conducted
speak out call right army with election
officials as we know based on what
happened in Georgia and the federal
charges that's illegal so I I think
we're going to have to ask the
Republicans to criminally charge this
judge uh this Trump appointee judge I'm
going to throw that I don't care who
appointed him I think that's what when I
went to cover opening statements that
was what was interesting about sitting
with the families was they were saying
like Kelly is a trump appointee he's
been some like he's been more flexible
about some things because a lot of them
go into this DC courthouse being like I
am in a hostile city where the jury is
already biased against our case and I
have a democrat-appointed judge they
feel doomed from the beginning and this
only uh affirms This Feeling from people
who support these people saying you know
the government is out to get us no
matter what I mean 300 people are in
jail because of January 6 over a
thousand have been charged federally it
just seems like I I can't imagine being
a business owner in a city where there
were significant writing rioting during
the summer of 2020 and thinking like wow
I wish someone cared about what happened
to me as much as DC cares about what
happens to itself I mean they
experienced so much there was so much
loss there and yet all of the focus is
on these people and one specific day it
seems it seems disproportionate to me
this is not
it it is it is an incredible naivety to
think that a 17-year sentence will set
an example for anybody the only example
this judge has set is that there is a
biased neolib neocon uniparty machine
that will destroy your life unjustly if
you speak out against them in any way
and of course that's not me defending
what Joe Biggs did in tearing down a
barricade and you know going into the
capital or whatever he should not have
done that I imagine Riot charge would be
a couple of months or something maybe
followed by probation or whatever
but when you look at the crimes
committed by the far left it is fairly
obvious they're they're being paid money
when the far leftists rioted in DC and
burned and set fire to buildings and
garbage in the street and the limousine
smashing Windows the city paid them
millions of dollars paid them after they
got arrested when it's the right at the
Capitol I mean look and you've also had
the left Storm Into the Senate and you
know buildings and and bang on the
Supreme Court doors and going to the
Capitol all of that not a peep nobody
cares so all that they're doing is
setting an example that you have
oppressors willing to use Force against
you to take you from your children and
like if you look at the forums is what
people are saying I I the radicalization
is terrifying and Joe Biden can do this
and then he's gonna say we're not tough
on cry or we are tough on crime we talk
about San Francisco and New York we
locked all these guys up from j6 what
they're gonna say we protect democracy
right they're gonna that's what we do
we're battling domestic terrorism never
mind what happens to the cities outside
of DC never mind the people who lost
their businesses in in 2020 we don't
care about what happens then we care
about what happens to us as the head of
the government this has got to be like
uh they're anticipating riots if they
take Trump off the ballot and they want
to intimidate people into not riding or
be like hey make an example of job don't
even think about it 17 years if you even
think about it kind of thing but like
you got to understand the damage it's
not people aren't machines they don't
they don't respond A to B like a like a
computer program and if you
just you just can't test twist this man
there's a reason that we have this this
system built like it's built so that
people in the center don't take control
uh I'm sorry about this let's jump to
this story from CNN the big news today
was Donald Trump pleading not guilty in
a Georgia elections election subversion
case and seeking to sever his case from
co-defendants who want a speedy trial
that's it Donald Trump uh sent in a
signed document saying that he was
waiving his right to appear he would be
pleading not guilty and we currently
await the uh the next steps which
they're trying uh funny William uh
Willis wants the trial to be March 4th
but that likely will not happen because
what we're hearing they've got uh 12
million documents released in Discovery
and there's absolutely no way a defense
could prepare in that short amount of
time so it's creating an interesting
predicament but the big news outside of
Trump's not guilty plea is the D.A
Bonnie Williams uh Willis lying to the
court
or uh it appears to the court in order
to justify withholding evidence we have
two tweets one from Adam classfeld
saying D.A Willis wants to advise all
the defendants in the Trump racketeering
case that Decisions by Ken chaseborough
and Sydney Powell to invoke Speedy Trail
rights come with certain consequences
Mike certovic responded this isn't even
true it's how it's it's not how the law
works but this really is a mask off
moment Fulton County D.A threatens to
violate the rights of the defendants
because she's not prepared for a trial
she actually said that if you request
your constitutional right for a speedy
trial you can't argue they're entitled
to Discovery they can't argue that
they're entitled to notice of the state
similar transaction evidence 10 days in
advance they are precluded from calling
any Witnesses whose statements were not
provided to the state 10 days in advance
and the defendants can can now complain
cannot now complain they have received
less than seven days notice
I'm seeing a ton of legal uh analysts
saying like wow she's outright lying and
if you actually look at the the cases
she's citing for precedent none of them
say what she's saying she's trying to
pull a fast one yes because they're evil
they're corrupt and at some point people
need to realize this is not law this is
not
a Judicial System
this is the exercise of political power
and the question that's being posed by
this judge in the proud voice case and
by the D.A in Georgia is can we get away
with it that's the question
and I wonder a lot of people said the
Supreme Court will intervene I don't
think the Supreme Court is going to
intervene as it pertains to the proud
boys
no no I don't I don't I I they might
intervene as it pertains to Trump but
we'll see but already we can see that
Democrats are willing to lie in court I
mean it's not surprising we saw Kyle
Rittenhouse they fabricated evidence
that's the craziest thing to try and
convict that kid here we are
I mean I don't think they have much of
anything and and the way the that I was
reading the indictments was basically
anytime Donald Trump complained about
something that was part of the
conspiracy so they they quite literally
were listing all of his tweets which he
has a lot in every single tweet is part
of the greater conspiracy at hand
um and and to me it makes me wonder like
does the president have the right
for freedom of speech does the president
have the right to complain
all right because I we we have all these
different situations in the past where
someone is contesting an election
and we have a process in place but
that's what we did he complained they
did a recount they went through the
process so are you now penalizing him
for complaining because that's what it
sounds like
um that's the case yeah
you go to prison for it now and a judge
will then Advocate others do the same
thing you did right so that's why the
Supreme Court I think will step in
because if it sets a precedent that you
can't complain about an election that
you disagree with and you can't bring
claims about an election that you
disagree with that would undermine the
Constitution the inherent aspect of the
U.S Constitution this allows us for a
redress of of our you know of our but
I'm I'm disagreement I keep hearing from
people saying you know we've gotten
super chats where they're like Tim stop
acting like the Supreme Court's not
going to shut this down and I'm like
just like they they uh responded to the
Texas V Pennsylvania lawsuit
when Texas said that these other states
are engaging in election practices in
violation of the Constitution thus
subverting a process we're involved in
the Supreme Court said no
and it's the craziest thing ever because
I feel like this it was Thomas and Alito
said we have to take this but the rest
of them were like nah we want you know
what the real the reality is they're
cowards and they just wanted the
election to be over with you know I was
talking to Will Chamberlain a long time
ago about it and he said
I think I said it on the show The issue
is that if they step into this lawsuit
it will expose them as having no
enforcement power and so the Supreme
Court really has to do light things when
they issue rulings it has to be done
such a way that it can reasonably be
accomplished but if they try and do
something more drastic like send back
five or six states electoral vote counts
to be re litigated thus changing the
results of the election
then there's questions as to whether or
not they can enforce any of these things
when people resist their their rulings
yeah if they ruled on this Trump case
and they were like no this is not
constitutional you had a right to
question the elections all the things he
did was constitutionally legal and then
the Biden Administration continues to go
forward with it after Supreme Court
declaration that would be just like
tearing the threads of society apart and
that's and that's what the Supreme
Court's worried about that if they do
issue a ruling and the Democrats don't
care and keep doing whatever they want
look at this way if the Supreme Court
intervenes and says this truck these
charges against Trump are
unconstitutional they violate the
supremacy clause blah blah blah and then
the Democrats say so what
Supreme Court no longer exists at that
point and they probably want that it's
like nine people and nine nine people in
the Supreme Court right now nine people
they buy their bodyguards
so it's like nine people with some some
protection against the entire federal
government the Ft or the FTA the uh the
CIA the NSA the FBI and then against
nine dudes sitting and of course some of
them are women but nine people sitting
on the Supreme Court like they don't
have power it's nine old people or like
nine judges I mean but that's true of
our whole system right like you have as
much power as you can they have as much
power as we can send to give them and
that was the idea of having these three
balances these branches that bounce each
other out that's that's technically
correct they have as much power as
police are willing to enforce against so
if the Supreme Court says something like
you can no longer uh bar people from
having guns
that's an interesting question in New
York they ruled that uh they said
president was set that women are allowed
to be topless because it is a violation
of the Civil Rights Act and
constitutional rights for men to be
allowed not to wear a shirt but women
being forced to wear a shirt
you still have cops arrest women
regularly for going topless because
those cops don't care what is legal they
care about their morals and so there's
apparently some like morbidly obese old
woman who's in her 50s who intentionally
goes around with just like massive old
saggy boobs and the police will be like
ma'am you need to put a shirt on and go
no I don't and they'll save them we're
gonna arrest you and she goes do it she
immediately files a lawsuit and they
instantly settle every single time
because it is illegal so why is that
these cops are willing to enforce on
enforce them this not a law or that's
not legally enforceable but they'll do
it anyway
so the issue then become the Supreme
Court comes in and says you have to
release Trump and they go no
Supreme Court's gonna bang the gavel
again well we order you to release Trump
no thank you and then what what's
supposed to happen like a rogue
executive branch is like no we're not
gonna then does is that when the FBI
turns on the executive branch no like
there are the executive branch who
guards the Supreme Court what's the the
military structure that protects the
Supreme Court from a crazy executive
Marshals I guess U.S Marshals
but I'm not sure that they're dedicated
explicitly to just the Supreme Court not
sure there's this Supreme Court
um I think they're the Supreme Court
police they might be getting their title
wrong because I remember when uh after
Roe v Wade came out one of the big
challenges was the fact that people you
know their homes a lot of their homes
had been docks and so they were needing
to sort of redouble the support that
their security had and remember Congress
specifically passing something to make
sure that the protection was extended to
their families because it had become so
critical because these writers just
stayed outside their house I guess
they're not writer suitors protesters
but yeah the the Marshals are the
enforcement arm of the U.S federal
courts that's cool that's uh Vivek wants
to move a lot of the FBI over to the U.S
Marshals
it sounds almost innocuous but that's a
big difference serving the executive
branch or serving the judicial branch I
didn't used to think it was a big
difference I thought it was all serving
the American government and I would like
it to maintain that and continue to be
that
I agree and I think that that makes
sense as far as uh Will Chamberlain was
saying that's why it has to be light
things it can't be something Grand
because who's going to enforce it you
know so you're talking about protecting
but protecting themselves but how do you
enforce something like that that when
you're talking about actually possibly
imprisoning someone uh you know for
something that great
and you know I don't think they have
much teeth they don't have any real way
of enforcing it so they like you said
they're kind of cowards and they die
from it I think that you combine what's
going on with Trump and the j6ers and uh
and like Joe Biggs and they are perhaps
intentionally creating a recipe for
disaster
they they want
an explosion I I wonder if the mentality
of these people is that either we win or
everyone loses
but why
I don't know uh there's a really funny
quote from Michael malice Pizza gate
aged better than russiagate
I'm not saying that's true I'm saying
these people fear criminal prosecution
for a variety of crimes like Joe Biden
engaging in the barisma Scandal the
things they accused Trump of turned out
to be lies in fact Ukraine gate was the
best because it turned out that Trump
was actually the good guy trying to weed
out the corruption and then they go and
protect Joe Biden instead so there are
criminals actively using law enforcement
against the just American people who are
trying to put a stop to their corruption
and it's unsurprising people who want to
play by the rules are being beaten down
by those who are cheating it's the exact
same scenario when you end up with a
Criminal with a gun breaking into a
liquor store and killing the clerk who
doesn't have a gun the law says you
can't have a gun so the criminals don't
care and do whatever they want and the
innocent civilians aren't aren't allowed
to protect themselves and Beca and get
victimized because of it and now you
have in the political system Republicans
being like well we gotta go slow and
play by the rules and Democrats are like
let's just cheat
do whatever we want lock them all up and
then if we lose well if we just burn it
all the ground
but I think this is
this is a much bigger thing talking
about how big the federal government has
become and you talked about the
establishment you know the the only time
the the mainstream media ever said that
Trump was presidential was when he
bombed Syria yeah they were very happy
about that they're very happy about that
um I think back to Obama one of the
reasons why people were disappointed by
Obama because Obama gave all these lofty
goals like these really big things that
he was going to do for the American
people and what did he do he went in and
played ball and did like what everybody
else does and guess what they loved him
for it but as soon as you start to
reject those things you start to not
play ball you start to reject the
establishment you start to reject War
you start to mess up with uh other
Industries
um calling out corruption nobody likes
that and I think this is this is the
counter effect to it so while some
people think it's the uh I don't like
his Mean Tweets really it's about him
challenging
the status quo
um well I don't think he's perfect but
there's there's a certain element that
pisses pisses people off and uh within
the federal government uh that he's
doing and I think this is part of the
punishment for doing so you guys are
playing civilization it's a game of
great games Tim you know it and it's as
if the U.S military-industrial complex
funnily enough was going for a military
Victory they're attempting to conquer
and control Earth with police state they
have military bases all over they want
order through military force then Trump
comes in he's like no I want to change
our Victory condition let's do something
cultural or something I don't even know
what his victory condition was but it
was a military
space space you want a technology
Victory so but they're like dude we have
all these troops we are paying for them
we cannot stop just stop we can't
disband our entire four we've spent
decades building this Army it's in
position and Trump's like I'm not doing
it though dude we cannot have this guy
run the country because he's screwing up
our military Victory I don't I don't
think it's I mean that's that's one way
to put it but the reality is Trump's
right now Trump is saying one yes bring
our troops home secure our borders bring
back manufacturing and you have people
who have built their whole lives around
the liberal economic order that is
maintain World Police
it's not that you know they want a
military Victory but I get your point
it's more so that Trump is saying how do
we make America better how do we improve
the lives of our citizens whereas these
people are like how do we control the
world citizens be damned
yeah and then that's why I feel like
when you asked earlier why would they
why would they do this I think it's
because well there's probably different
people would do it for different reasons
some people probably because he's called
Rosie O'Donnell a fat pig and they're
like I I will do anything to not have
that in my life you know these really
but some people are afraid like he's
going to screw up the victory condition
this well let's uh let's go to the dark
side from this uh uh from timcast.com
Tucker Carlson says America is speeding
toward assassination of Donald Trump
that's a scary Prospect he said they
process protested him they called him
names he won anyway they impeached him
twice on ridiculous pretenses they
fabricated a lot about what happened on
January 6 in order to impeach him again
it didn't work he came back then they
indicted him it didn't work he became
more popular then they indicted him
three more times and every single time
his popularity rose so if you begin with
criticism then you go to a protest and
you go to impeachment and you go to
indictment none of them work what's next
I mean you know graph it out man we're
speeding toward assassination obviously
and no one will say that but I don't
know how you can't reach that conclusion
you know what I mean like they have
decided permanent Washington both
parties have decided that there's
something about Trump that's so
threatening to them they just can't have
them
he later commented I don't know where
it's going but there's a collusion
that's clearly imminent I've never been
this worried about anything as I am
about where this is going
if people don't get serious about their
comfort zones I think they're going to
demonize him and diet him indict him and
diet him indict him and I think they'll
blow his airplane up Jones says Alex
Jones I really at a gut level believe
they're going to kill Trump
there was a story in I think it was 2015
a guy tried grabbing a gun from a cop at
a trump rally there's already been
threats made against Donald Trump and I
guess we can only hope and pray it
doesn't come to that but Tucker makes a
really interesting point
now I will counter he's not gotten Pop
more popular every time they've indicted
him because I I I tracked the
favorability and popular trump it is
stable
stable is
is potentially as bad or worse
stable means
that there are people who don't care
what the government does or says they
will never abandon Trump that's it it
also says there are people that no
matter what will never support Trump
right if Trump got more or less popular
because the indictments that would mean
something becoming less popular means
there are people who supported him but
now are backing away if he becomes more
popular it means that people who didn't
support him are starting to support him
no it hasn't changed because it's locked
in right now the left and the right
whatever you want to call it the
political factions are stable and that
means all of the things they're doing
are just radicalizing people and and
making the Flames bigger and more
dangerous which I kind of assume is what
they want right I don't know
I mean
it's
man there's a lot of scenarios in my
mind but if Tucker is correct I don't
see how this country survives another
year two years year and a half I don't I
don't think Tucker's correct I forget
who we had on the show but he said you
can't in 2023 you can't do what you did
in the 60s right you can't give somebody
the Kennedy treatment I think they've
already done it to Trump and we've seen
it it's the indictments it's the
mainstream media with all the pieces
throughout his presidency it's all of
that that they've already taken them
down or at least attempted I don't think
so I don't think Trump trump is
predicted to win right now if you if so
CNN reported this not my opinion calm
down crackpots CNN said right now based
on all the data they got it's looking
really good for Trump now I take into
consideration that the student loan debt
about to kick back on in the next couple
of weeks think about this
so I was talking to my girlfriend about
this earlier I said you know uh we I was
passively talking about it and then she
was like wait they're they're everyone's
got to pay back their student loans
again starting in a couple weeks and I'm
like yeah something like that and then
she was like they're not going to have
the money and I'm like right exactly and
then I said in the question then becomes
how do they pay for their student loans
if right now we got all these videos of
young people saying I can't afford my
bills
how are they going to pay back their
student loans if student loan repayment
restarts they're not
and then I'm like so so it's kind of
like 2008 they gave out loans to people
who didn't have credit couldn't afford
it and then my girlfriend was like well
they got their parents to co-sign she's
like a lot of these people got their
parents to co-sign and I was like
interesting then when these 27 28 year
olds don't pay back their loans and then
the lenders say
your you know your your mom or dad is a
co-signer and goes to them and says you
got to pay and then they go we can't
afford to pay they go then we take your
house and we're seeing tick tocks of
people that age crying saying I did what
I was supposed to do I got the degree I
work hard I don't party I did everything
I was supposed to do and I can't afford
food and I guarantee if it becomes
between student loans and putting food
on your table you're not gonna pay the
student loans so you're gonna let them
default but then what are you gonna do
when you're like sorry Mom and Dad oh
exactly I'm gonna you're gonna lose your
house you're gonna have to pay the
consequence of my actions I mean that is
the result of the student loan thing but
I think it's going to make a very
divided and bitter Society a bailout
yeah also the only the only circumstance
that seems to make sense would be a
government bailout of the student loan
system and that is going to be a
disaster because that's another trillion
plus instantly pumped into the economy
by way of forgiveness which will cause
massive inflation or is already
contributed to it but oh boy if you
thought Richmond north of Richmond was
bad wait till you go to the likes of
Oliver Anthony and say oh here's the
best part the highest income runners in
the country who have nothing but disdain
for you and told you told you to go
learn to code just got a 50 000 freebie
from the government yeah and if that
happened that would mean pumping another
trillion in would mean that your dollar
is worth like 96 cents right after that
happens all those people that already
paid their loans back that have their
money devalued are gonna go I mean maybe
not all of them but it's not a lot of
them get angry at people that are taking
tits off the taking the government's tip
to go back to the the initial story like
Tucker is saying where does it go next
people need to consider that none of
this stuff is happening in a vacuum and
when it came to the lockdowns uh and the
George Floyd riots I actually think the
lockdowns were the cause of the riots
not George Floyd we had seen protests
before I do not believe the George Floyd
video is the reason why we had such
massive and widespread writing I think
the writing was likely
people were fed up they were locked in
their homes they were angry they had no
income their purpose was stripped they
were becoming an unhinged and depressed
and then they were given some you know a
spark for the Tinder a lot of people
will probably say it was George Floyd
whatever
the media definitely said it was George
Floyd but I think we talked about it at
the time that this pent-up rage from
being locked up so you take a look at
what's going on with Donald Trump as
president
you take a look what's happening now
with student loan repayment about to
kick in the economy may fall off a cliff
in the next couple of months we got the
guy from Shark Tank saying it you got
Michael burry of big short Fame who
shorted the housing market making a 1.6
billion dollar bet against the S P 500
and NASDAQ I think both it might just be
s p
and we don't know if he's if he's uh uh
actually cashed out yet or where he's at
but he made a very very big bet against
the US economy and the student loan
repayment seems to make the most sense
people who don't have jobs who can't
afford to pay their bills being told the
bill comes due they're not going to pay
it if you go up to a 27 year old and say
you can pay your rent you can buy your
gas or you can buy food or you can pay
your student loans they're going to say
okay well if I don't have food I die if
I don't have gas I can't go to work and
can't make money and if I don't pay a
runtime homeless sorry student loans
ain't getting paid for anybody that has
student loans that isn't able to afford
them right now you can do two things you
can put them on a forbearance or you can
put them on a deferment depending on
your income level so look into that that
can you can set them off for years and
not have to pay them but isn't most of
the student loan debt basically owe to
the government yes
over 90 I think it's like 90 at minimum
94 the majority of it is owned by the
government so the government gave you
bad loans and then is saying you have to
pay them actually we might just bail
ourselves out we don't know what we're
gonna do I mean it's a terrible system
and we're still issuing student loans
sorry I don't want to cut you off no no
it's a point of irritation with me
because it just seems like a terrible
business model you get the US
government's like no it's fine keep
getting student loans go to college
that's the answer even though we have
evidence it's so clear the system is
broken and potentially could destroy
generations of a family that have worked
really hard to to create Financial
stability yeah I completely agree and
and speaking from a perspective of a
father my son is 17 he'll be 18 October
um and I've even written articles about
this and talked about it on TV
you know Raising a Son
um and you know someone who's looking
like me the older he gets and I'm
thinking about
his prosperity
the only thing I've ever been worried
about with my son is what is he going to
do as far as College that's the only
thing I wasn't worried about puberty I
wasn't worried about any of that stuff
worrying about him you know being
rebellious never worried about that the
only thing I've ever been worried about
probably since the age of 12 is like oh
my God my son's about to be a teenager
and he's going to start thinking about
what he's going to do after school and I
think about how unfair of a message it
is to to spread to kids that the only
way for you to find success is a sign on
the dotted line you have no credit
history right you have no income you
have no job prospects but you have to
sign on the dotted line and have hope
that whatever your intending to pursue
is going to work out and obviously
that's not what happens and every year
some kid is competing against you and so
on and so forth and they're unprepared
and then you send them out into the
world so they work at Starbucks making
minimum wage
and tell them they have to pay back
eighty thousand dollars meanwhile their
parents told them well that's what we
did yes but you're not in their
situation you're not dealing with a
gouging student loan Market you're not
dealing with universities who can charge
whatever they want because the federal
government will pay it anyways right
they're not dealing with these things
and parents as a parent I'm saying other
parents have given their children bad
information and they're not being aware
of what is actually going on they're
just telling them to follow my footsteps
or they're following their footsteps
into Financial hell basically
yeah it's like the area that they walked
through is now flooded and they tell
their kid to walk back through it that's
not a good tactic it's like when parents
say well why don't you just go work at
McDonald's that's how I paid my way
through college yeah you can't do that
these days so how did you inspire your
son what's his next move what if what
advice did you give him I told him I
told him the truth I told him that
college is incredibly expensive and you
need to weigh all options there is a
period of time that he wanted to do
um uh Artistry and he wanted to go over
to Japan I I've told him go to other
countries Japan's good yeah now he's
changed that idea and he's still
thinking about it but I'm not one of
those parents like you have to do
something as soon as you turn 18. he
wants to go bounce around Europe next
year but he's working he's been working
this entire time we've we started doing
homeschooling but I'm having him think
for himself rather than force a
narrative onto him that the only way to
find success in this world is through
college and for me as someone who uh
worked in I.T I did the same job as
everybody else who got their computer
science degree I I went to a 11-month
program you know for a tech school
instead of four years of bachelor's and
crazy amounts of tuition yeah I pay my
student loans are are paid off so you
know there are alternatives and I think
parents just have to be aware that what
you went through is not what these kids
are going through they're set up for
failure going that route they're set up
for a lifetime of a financial hurt and
radicalization and radicalization one
other thing I just want to add
we're talking about the economy dipping
interest rates for housing you know my
wife and I are looking to buy a house
next year we're looking at the interest
rate what's the situation that we're
going to be facing so now the kids have
I don't know how much money in debt the
interest rates are going up so even if
some kid able to find a decent job they
can't afford to to purchase a home
rent's gone up one of the reasons we're
looking to buy a house is because we
renewed our lease 300 increase yep now
thankfully we have we make decent income
together but we're a married couple what
about these kids right so I just I
foresee I foresee the Europe is uh like
a European style setup that's happening
in America because all the European
adults that I know most of them live
with other people live with other adults
we all have roommates that's where we're
gone yeah I want to jump to this story
from timcast.com
Alabama attorney general says the state
can prosecute people who facilitate
out-of-state abortions Alabama will not
permit abortionists to defy our laws and
enrich themselves by marketing
hopelessness to women
what did I say what did I say uh
a few months ago what did I say when Roe
v way was overturned my concern is that
you will end up in a situation where a
state that bans abortion
says or in encounters a conflict with
its citizens its residents and a state
that has Limitless abortion this is a
component of that escalation
we've talked about even recently
Colorado and Oklahoma where in Oklahoma
it's completely been in Colorado it's
completely unrestricted what happens
when there's a couple there together
they have a they you know get pregnant
as it were and then after six months the
woman says I'm just really unhappy and
maybe Justified Maybe not maybe she's a
good person maybe she's cheating and she
wants to leave so she goes I cannot
leave my husband unless I get rid of
this baby so at let's say seven or eight
months she flees in the middle of the
night to Colorado the man then says the
baby can survive and she's going to kill
it and he reports her to law enforcement
would Oklahoma take action now
apparently as of now no but this is what
Alabama has effectively begun the
process of and not even in the scenario
I described in the scenario where you
have like a guy saying please officer
law enforcement the baby is eight months
you know gestated and can survive
outside of the womb do not let her kill
it I will raise it on my own she can
leave I don't care and she says no I
don't care I'm gone I'm gonna go do it
there's a conflict in Alabama they're
just saying outright and they can do it
here's the story
Alabama has the power to prosecute
people who help women leave the state to
get an abortion according to a new
filing from the Attorney General Stephen
Steve Marshall Marshall has challenged a
lawsuit filed by two pro-abortion groups
the ACLU and the yellowhammer fund
against the state
the AGS asked the United States district
court for the Middle District of Alabama
to dismiss the lawsuit in his motion to
dismiss Marshall pointed out the
plaintiffs are not challenging the
constitutionality of the state's
broadband and abortions
instead they argue that because some
other states allows to abortion
plaintiffs have a right to conspire with
others in Alabama to try and have
abortions performed out of state
plaintiffs are mistaken Prosecuting
someone for forming a conspiracy in
Alabama is not an extraterritorial
application of Alabama Law simply
because the planned conduct is to occur
Beyond state lines plaintiffs assert
that there is some difference because
the object of their conspiracy is legal
where it might occur but they don't
explain why that makes any
constitutional difference and it doesn't
the conspiracy is what is what is being
punished even if the conduct never
occurs that conduct is alabama-based and
within Alabama's power to prohibit now
to take that interpretation of the law
and apply it to uh the store the
scenario I was just proposing a woman in
the middle of the night decides she's
going to leave her husband and travel to
another state to get an abortion so that
she can eventually so she can leave him
the state then says premeditated murder
not the act itself or getting you for
what you planned in our state and we
have evidence that you packed up
prepared and sought to leave to go get
Aid in the killing of a human life and
did she talk to anyone before did she in
any way get advice from get funding from
Planned Parenthood for instance what
happens then in Alabama let's let's go
to Alabama right now the question I ask
you
under this ruling a woman goes to a
Planned Parenthood or an underground
Clinic look but Planned Parenthood is
probably a better example
and they say
she you know I want to get an abortion
we can't do it in state but don't worry
here's the information you need to cross
the borders what happens then when the
AG gets a bunch of state troopers and
they surround a Planned Parenthood and
say you are all under arrest for
criminal conspiracy to commit abortion
I'm not saying that happens anytime soon
I honestly don't know my point is this
this is exactly what I was worried about
when I said with Roe v Wade the next
grain of sand in the Heap is going to be
law enforcement saying we've banned
abortion doesn't mean you can just go do
it somewhere else it's illegal
and then what happens when a person is a
fugitive from the law
for getting an abortion in you know
let's say let's say Oklahoma Colorado is
the best example Oklahoma petitions as
everyone's talked about with Trump and
the marshals and how it would go down
Oklahoma petitions the federal
government says a fugitive from law is
currently in Colorado what happens when
Colorado says we're a sanctuary for
abortion and we will not allow you to
enforce this warrant you got the makings
of federal and Interstate conflict yeah
it is kind of hard to understand what
will happen I I really don't know
um Alabama is an interesting study for a
couple reasons their abortion ban won't
uh that says women who obtain abortions
are not uh civilly or criminally liable
so they couldn't go after the woman
herself for going out of state but they
could go after like the yellow Hammer
fund would pay for her travel let's say
or put up on a hotel so they could go
after anyone who's involved with that
organization the thing about Alabama to
note is that they have the human life
protection act which passed in 2019
which is also interesting because I
remember pre-row we were all talking
about this was sort of something a lot
of states were preparing for they were
updating their their abortion related
laws and with the human life protection
act act it uh defines the fetus as a
person legally and so in Alabama in
Alabama wow so again they were taking
steps to Define all of these things that
we debate and that are debated
nationally all the time because they
have a strong position on it and what
they want to do and like I said I think
it's hard to tell what would happen
every state has different laws so with
Alabama they wouldn't go after the woman
they would go after you know her friend
who drives her out of state maybe or or
the the uh the whoever pays for her
hotel or something like what if she
calls an Uber and gets an Uber across
state lines do they arrest the Uber
driver for conspiracy even if they
didn't know what was going on I mean I
think it would be hard to
if like that did happen the rest of the
Uber driver and this is I'm not a lawyer
just playing one on this podcast
apparently uh but if the Uber driver
took someone out of state and then had
to go to court and was like I had no
idea I've never met this person I worked
for Uber it would be very hard to then
have a conviction in my opinion yeah how
could you ever prove conspiracy unless
you have a recorded conversation right
but if it's a couple and you know they
get pregnant accidentally and they go
out of uh out of state could if the
woman can't be uh criminally or
similarly similarly challenged could her
boyfriend who drove right but why why
can't she be why can't the pregnant
woman herself be criminally charged
that's just the Alabama Law and a lot of
states have something like that that a
judge will probably strike that down in
two seconds I mean the law is in effect
but maybe if it were to go to trial it
it if this gets tested you can't have a
scenario where a woman is sitting a
pregnant woman sits down next to her not
pregnant friend and the pregnant woman
says I want to abort this baby and the
friend says I can give you information
on a clinic and then they go ah but only
the woman who said you know where the
clinic was Goes to Jail what the
initiator of the criminal conspiracy is
the pregnant woman herself now I'm not
saying women should be imprisoned for
seeking abortions not not at all I'm
actually the the more uh old school
Democrat pro-choice position I'm just
saying these two laws can't lead they
can't legally exist because you're going
to end up with someone challenging the
constitutionality of the criminal
conspiracy saying for what reason does
this one criminal act have an exception
where the person who initiates the
conspiracy is exempt from the law and
the judges have to say you can't do that
either the law applies to everybody or
nobody and if the law itself is
conspiracy and not abortion then the
pregnant woman must be charged with
conspiracy along with her friend but the
part that confuses me is that you're
saying that Alabama says that the fetus
is a human being so wouldn't it be
conspiracy to murder right it's a great
question
I mean I'm just trying to think of like
what's the actual charge personally I
don't think that there's enough here
I don't think there would be enough here
to prove the the conspiracy angle
um and on top of that is there much
enforcement for it like you can create
as many laws as you want is there going
to be much enforcement what does
enforcement look like right yeah I hate
this idea of arresting charging someone
for something they did outside of the
jurisdiction where it was illegal like
like weeds illegal in a state so you go
to a state where it's legal get high you
come back and they're like you're you're
a fugitive you just broke the law no I
didn't to clarify the AG is literally
saying
you are right and that the crime that's
being punished is the conspiracy to
commit an act the conspiracy to go smoke
so could you imagine if they try and
bust you on a conspiracy to go to a
state where something
that happens all the time
that is absolutely normal has been
around for hundreds of years if you are
in a state and you come together with
buddies and plot a crime in another
state regardless
yeah if it's not a crime in the other
state you're plotting to go another
state to gamble for instance I'm going
to Vegas to gamble is that conspiracy
now because it's illegal here that's why
the the uh return general statement of
like it's an Alabama Law and it's
illegal here and so that's what matters
is what I just I don't think that a
state can can decide what I can do in
another state that's insane it's
interesting for sure I mean the idea
what it makes me think of is like how
powerful all the states and how
important is state residency right like
if you claim residency in that state are
you supposed to obey those laws more
than anything else even when you're in
other states I will say the I uh it
would be interesting to contrast this
law to um the Idaho abortion trafficking
law so Idaho Force Washington Washington
is uh basically very pro-abortion
they've got all kinds of times you can
get you can you can undergo an abortion
but Idaho was much more restrictive and
so they had this abortion trafficking
law saying like if in if I'm remembering
the language correctly it's specific to
minors so if a minor got pregnant and
approached Planned Parenthood or
approach you know know a friend's mom
and so can you please take me to
Washington or wherever Washington is
just a key example uh to get an abortion
that adult could be uh brought up on
criminal charges because they are uh if
they don't tell the miners parents so if
they traffic a kid out a pregnant
teenager out of the state to get an
abortion and bring them back that's
against an Idaho law and the governor of
Washington was really adamant that this
was a terrible idea and I asked him to
take it down in inmate you make a really
really good point about the absurdity of
a system based on pure logic that would
say if it's illegal here you cannot plan
to do it and that's interesting because
uh you mentioned gambling Texas friends
I just did a quick cursory search
largely illegal to gamble in Texas it is
a crime to place Wagers on sporting
events and you know card games they have
card houses for the most part where
you're allowed to do it so it's it's
questionable as to what they determined
to be gambling and I guess the issue
with poker in Texas is that it's
considered a skill game so it doesn't
fall in the same category but the
biggest casino I think in the country is
on the border just north of Texas in
Oklahoma and that's where everyone
drives to to go clearly you have to talk
with your friends and make a plan to go
drive up to the world's biggest the
country's biggest casino I think maybe
in one of the world's biggest casinos
and then I think it's like a mile wide
or something and then uh commit crimes
but what that really tells us is our
legal system is based on culture and
morality and not the written letter of
the law like I said a million and one
times it's illegal for women to skydive
on Sunday in Florida Google it it's true
they don't arrest anyone for doing it
right there's a ton of laws in the books
like you can't put an apple pie on the
windowsill on Tuesday because it
mattered back then but doesn't matter
now
what the ques the question where that's
being asked right now is
as our culture breaks down
and law becomes the pure exercise of
power all that matters and I guess this
is actually a more black pilled
prescription or or
um
perception perspective uh
when you're looking at the Joe Biggs
case and they're saying we're going to
give him 17 years because he's a
terrorist it's like were the terrorist
laws written to prevent a guy from
knocking down a four foot steel
barricade I don't I don't think so I
think they were written because we're
concerned about people blowing stuff up
but now it's being applied in a way that
they've decided they can morality be
damned you have the question of
skydiving in Florida no one's going to
enforce that because nobody left or
right would agree with the enforcement
of it no one in Texas agrees that you
should criminally prosecute someone for
conspiracy because they went to go
gamble a 45 minutes away in Oklahoma but
you're right they did conspire to commit
a crime in the future and it doesn't
matter where they do it so now the
question is when it comes to abortion
what will we see in terms of the
morality you are going to have AGS who
are pro-life
you hear Sheamus on the show when he
says abortion should be banned
Nationwide
in in the moral view of a pro-life AG
abortion must be stopped in a state like
Alabama where they've banned it
they are going to use the law to
whatever
novel uh claim they can to enforce a ban
an abortion it sounds like uh the
beginning of a pre- attempted pre-crime
where they're going to get you and
arrest you before you do the crime just
by thinking about it kind of thing I
don't like it but conspiracy is a
component of a criminal action but but I
think the the issue here is you're right
but it shows that that laws are only
enforced based on what our society deems
to be morally acceptable and acceptable
no one would stand for a couple of
drinking buddies being like we got to go
up to Oklahoma on Sunday and hit the
blackjack tables and the cops bust in
the door but like you're busted for
conspiracy to gamble show me your ID and
no one would have thought this be this
possible either but the issue of
abortion is so morally polarized that
Oklahoma Colorado it's banned there what
happens if you get an AG maybe they
won't do it now but let's let's give it
a few years a new AG comes in and he's
thinking I want to win political points
because I want to run for the governor
governor's office I want to run for the
Senate the only way I do it is if I if I
cater to the wands and desires or the
people of my state polls come out saying
67 80 percent of Oklahomans want
abortion banned and people who get
abortions to be criminally charged he's
going to go okay if I am the AG of
ending abortion I'm going to win the
governor's race in four years so what
does he do conspiracy to commit abortion
conspiracy to facilitate abortion sends
police to the Border
what I think we're seeing with the
polarization of politics in this country
is Democrats aren't going to stop
because their base demands it they want
to get elected they'll do whatever they
have to Republicans don't want to stop
because they want to get reelected and
they'll do what Their base says both
sides are demanding more and more uh
dissociative outcomes or dissociated
outcomes the right says no abortion the
left has unlimited abortion and now
their states have to escalate that
policy and procedure which means in
states with unrestricted abortion
they need to add more to it now they're
going to have to you got Gavin Newsom I
think it's Newsom right here in the
article saying we will not cooperate
with any state that attempts to
prosecute women or doctors for receiving
or providing reproductive care now we're
seeing the escalation not only will
these states allow unlimited and
unrestricted abortion meaning a baby at
nine months they're also saying they
will defy federal law enforcement from
trying to stop a woman from traveling to
their state to get an abortion in
defiance of their own State's laws the
right will then have to escalate in kind
like this Alabama AG is outright saying
we will arrest you for conspiracy before
you get the chance there is going to be
an escalation Gavin Newsom will then say
we will use the powers of our government
to protect you if they try to persecute
you and then Alabama will say if the
feds won't do it we will send our law
enforcement or hire private contractors
to go and retrieve the criminal Fugitive
that's where you lose me I don't know
how States will have the um excuse me
have the resources to do this if we're
truly saying women start to flee the
state for abortions I don't think any
state has the Manpower it's called G4S
what is uh what is it security private
security company it's called Securitas
then you've got pmcs if it really comes
to the point basically mercenaries
Mercenaries
are you kidding me mercenaries hunt down
women that's insane well look at look at
where we're at right now
states are either Banning it out right
and threatening to criminally prosecute
those involved like Alabama is or
they're doing the inverse saying that
there is no restriction at all on the on
when an abortion can take place and they
will defy the federal government from
intervening in a warrant it is so wild
that the states are so different like
that what I what do you think what's
your well I was actually thinking that I
don't know if this is even something
that could work
there could be something where we start
seeing temporary residencies for women
who are getting abortions right because
when I got an abortion I wasn't a
resident of Alabama I was a resident of
a neighboring state and I think that
could be the way that they kind of
subvert that conspiracy charge so these
women or anybody who tries to help them
because they became a resident and then
a month later they had the abortion so
you can't say we conspired in this other
state so I think that could be something
um and if States like California are
like the polar opposite well if they're
going to do that we're going to do this
then that could be something that you
see someone like Gavin Newsom saying
well you know what if they're saying
they can't have abortions we're gonna
not only we're gonna say they can do it
here but we're gonna put them in housing
here too so they don't get those charges
they're just good it's going to keep
escalating I don't know about making it
like some sort of police force or
anything like that or going private
security I think then the next step
would be
finding legal ways where they can get
away with it and I think temporary
housing would be one of those things
they can claim residency for a period of
time while they have an abortion and
then they can move but but it's all it's
it's all a great Super Chat someone
quoting steved saying it's a we're not a
nation of laws We're a nation of
political will from Jason
um Hutchinson and so it doesn't matter
what anyone does it doesn't matter what
legal loophole someone tries to create
it just matters that an aging out of the
state says I don't care what you call it
right you got one judge telling the
proud boys you should have called an
election official or wrote to them you
got another another D.A saying because
you wrote to election officials and
asked them to help you you're going to
jail we're going to criminally charge
you yeah so it's just it's an issue of
willpower I want to jump back to student
loans though the story we were looking
at is from CNN student loan interest
resumes Friday and payments restart in
October here's what borrowers should
know for the first time in more than
three years federal student loan borrows
borrowers will be required to pay their
monthly student loan Bills starting in
October the pandemic related pause which
went into effect March 2020 provided
relief to nearly 44 million borrowers by
freezing their accounts
interest will start accruing again on
September 1st after rates were
effectively set to zero
uh since March 2020 we know that now
interest rates which are fixed and vary
by loan will return to the same rate
they were before the freeze but
borrowers still won't need to take any
action until their first monthly payment
is due which means if you don't take
action you will be accruing interest on
your debt and then have to pay more
money and for most as an aside the
difference between forbearance and a
deferment is that a forbearance means
you don't have to pay but you're still
accruing interest whereas a deferment
you don't pay but you don't accrue
interest and those are ideal you know if
you're going to put them off for most
borrowers the first payment will be due
sometime in October but not everyone has
the same date the exact same date
borrowers can expect to receive their
bill listing their payment around the
due date at least 21 days beforehand
so uh this will my payments be the same
they generally will be how do I find out
blah blah blah my payments were
automatic before but these questions
aren't really as relevant what happens
if I don't pay my student loan bill
because interest will start accruing on
September 1st not making a payment will
result in a borrower owing more on their
student loans over time but for the next
year through September 30 2024 the
government is providing what it's
calling an on-ramp period during which
borrowers are shielded from other normal
consequences of missing a payment a loan
servicer for uh won't for example report
the loan as being in default to the
national credit rating agencies
borrowers don't need to apply for this
benefit
this is one of the funnier elements of
this it means that as the economy starts
crumbling and debt spirals out of
control you won't be able to know about
it because they're not going to report
the delinquencies that means when that
on-ramp period ends you're going to see
delinquencies from like three percent to
like 43 overnight
I wonder if we get to a point just like
we were just talking about with laws
where people like I don't I don't
respect that law people are just like I
don't respect my debt
this is like I'm never gonna be able to
play this off I'm not going to deal with
it like there's something I can do I
mean ultimately theoretically with
consequences but this is why the
argument of like Joe Biden campaigned on
I am going to forgive student loans that
was him saying essentially I'm gonna
bail you guys out and that's what people
why people feel attached to him I think
and why it's potentially the biggest
flaw in his campaign because there were
people who need are counting on the fact
that they will not have to pay these
loans because they see it as an
impossible Financial hurdle
I was gonna say the the biggest problem
for me is that there's no
um there's nothing stopping it from
happening again if they were to bail
everybody out right because they stopped
issuing government-backed student loans
which they won't do they still haven't
done it sorry well even on top of that
they're not doing anything as far as the
universities what's their culpability to
it like why why does the same school
that that taught your parents how can
they cost 10 times more no no one
addresses that but they can just charge
whatever they want and the government
just packs it up how come the government
doesn't have stipulations right why
can't you default on student loans right
why can't we do well then yeah you used
to be able to I think George Bush Jr
made it illegal to bankrupt your student
loans 2003 or something right because
and I'm willing to bet I could be wrong
it's because the federal government
stepped up even more with student loans
so they said if we're going to step up
even more and invest in the American
public we can't have them all defaulting
because that would default the
government well here we are
rather than just be like maybe this
isn't a great system maybe we should
consider not issuing these maybe we
shouldn't be so obsessed with college
being the one path to anywhere in
America oh I'm sorry I get the banks are
for-profit so they want to charge you
interest to make money which is
disgusting but that's the system but
that the government is doing this
for-profit that they're going to loan me
money and then expect interest back like
they loan me 20 grand I don't want to
pay them back more than 20 grand I've
already paid 13 000 in interest but
that's it's not so much about a profit
it's about how the modern monetary
system works and with the creation of
the money supply what they want you to
do is pay back uh Grant don't get me
wrong like a lot of these interest rates
are greater than greater than the rate
of inflation but a component of it is if
uh the economy is inflating by three
percent we want you to pay back
comparable buying power if we give you a
hundred apples we want 100 apples back
guess what in a year apples are going to
cost more money you're gonna need more
money to pay back I would I'd be down
with that if they if they if you paid
back with a your increase with inflation
if it went up with inflation that would
be understandable that would be
logistical but this just flat out
interest rates compound interest on 18
year olds that don't aren't taught about
compound interest full predatory man and
I I don't refuse to pay back the
interest I'm not interested in doing it
here's the story from entrepreneur.com
this gets worse before it gets better
Kevin O'Leary warns of real chaos set to
hit the U.S economy this fall
but this was interesting I saw this a
couple of days ago he said you're
starting to see the chips fall the
layering is as follow the regional Banks
don't know yet what their Capital
requirements are going to be so their
loan books are have closed like a turtle
in a shell this gets worse before it
gets better and what's it doing to small
business killing them right now O'Leary
argued that enough money is being pumped
into small businesses and blame most
recent fed hikes including a benchmark
raise of 0.25 last month the only thing
I really care about this article is it's
another high profile business person
sounding the alarm bells in the economy
and after learning about what's about to
happen with student loans kicking in and
a lot of people not being able to pay
them back it is not unreasonable in my
opinion that that could be a large
Catalyst or at least a small component
of I don't know if it's be the big
component of the small component of some
kind of economic crisis especially if it
hits the the co-signers on the student
on the student loan debt and then of
course you have I've mentioned several
times Michael burry betting against the
U.S stock market
it seems like the people who have a lot
of money
are concerned the Market's going to take
a hit I have no idea what that means I
got people asking me every day like
should I buy property right now I'm like
I had no idea because they're like but
if the Market's going to crash I'm like
maybe probably I have no I have no idea
what upsets me the most and so
infuriating is we get these jobs numbers
out every month and the White House or
mainstream media take your pick they put
this positive little spin on it and wrap
it up in a little bow rather than just
telling the Americans hey here's the
problem and here's what you guys can do
as citizens of this country to help
everybody and work towards resolving
this problem because it is so complex
and there's no easy solution out of this
the economy yeah yes I mean this all
ties into the state of the economy right
now it's not monetary that's for sure
we're not going to fix the economy by by
another kind of money it's going to be
through materials I talked with Stu
Peters about this I believe it's live on
his uh channel on Rumble but I'll be
posting a link on that and Twitter later
uh the interview I do with Stu Peters
it's it's technology if we can make
energy cheaper make fuel cheaper then
the economy has become better and so if
you make if a tenth of the economy is
fuel and you make that a tenth cheaper
you basically
made one percent of your economy you've
made your economy a one percent better
you know so it's like
that's why I'm obsessed with hydrogen
fuel right now like I feel like we can
make cheap fuel make cheap heat
electricity building materials
transportation you know the basics you
know you know the trouble is is when you
see these videos at a Time Square where
someone goes up to another person and
says name a country that starts with the
letter U and they can't do it or they
say like who's the current president of
the United States and they can't they
don't know it and they'll say like when
did America get its independence and
they'll be like 1871. like they've no
idea and you have a lot of these people
they vote and when you see these videos
there are powerful individuals who then
are deeply offended that these people
are consuming resources and polluting
and so they turn around and say stuff
like we need to get a control on
overpopulation because there's too many
of these people weighing us down you
then get phrases like useless eaters you
get weird International policies such as
you will own nothing and you will be
happy and ultimately that means Ian you
will not get your cold fusion and your
spaceships because in the event that
there's an energy Revolution on par with
like this level of Fusion Energy which
is insane that would mean a massive and
explosive population boom that's for
sure and there's a lot of powerful
people who don't want that to happen
you think with how expensive college is
we'd be seeing some more of this uh
these technological advancements we
wouldn't be seeing train derailments in
East Palestine with how much Americans
are paying for college but we're not
we're not because like college is a is a
business right like I don't even know
that all degrees are equal and I think
there are programs that are probably
great but generally people are paying to
have their certificate they are not
actually always advancing to the level
that we'd like them see or that would be
implied by the fact that you went to
college a lot of people are in debt
basically having graduated by the skin
of their teeth and Having learned
nothing I mean there are colleges that
close during covet because the
enrollment is so low and because
ultimately the business of college is
failing you know you know small rabbit
monkey said yes you will Ian don't
listen to Tim
no I think we will but it's think
there's powerful individuals who are
trying to reduce population and they
have a they have a reasonable fear
because if every human had access to
unlimited energy Timothy McVeigh what
else would he have blown up like the a
psycho-terrorist that had a horrible
childhood just beat that hates Humanity
has access to unlimited power like
that's severely dangerous so I
understand why but there's scales I
don't want to give everyone cold fusion
packs just yet but hydrogen fuel it's
lightweight and could be cheaper than
gasoline I I'm thinking about what is
about to hit the economy and perhaps the
only solution is going to be student
loan debt forgiveness in some capacity
it was easy to say when we were talking
about 24 and 25 year olds up to maybe
like early 30s that we don't want to
forgive student loans these older people
have all paid them back it's like look
these people hate the why it's not fair
there's a lot of questions about
fairness about making the working class
pay the bills of the highest income
earners
but I think there is a a harsh reality
too
whatever your opinion is you're
presented with two
parent factions or parent paths to take
one we do not bail out the people who
have student loan debt and then these
people who are in their mid to late 30s
and 40s don't have families don't have
kids don't buy property become angry and
purposeless and and violent
or we do bail them out and the people
who are supposed to be the Crux of the
economy
resume working have the load taken off
their backs and it stabilizes things a
little bit
it's a question about the 2008 crisis
when they bailed out the banks do you
let the economy just course correct
shock everybody there is going to be
large amounts of death because of this
because of the economic crisis or do you
bail out alleviate some of the crisis
extend it for a little longer but reduce
the amount of death it's serious
questions I think that the the
reasonable approach that the government
will likely want to take is going to be
a bailout whether Joe Biden wants to or
not and in fact you may see this in 2024
Joe Biden coming out and saying one of
the biggest drags in our economy right
now is student loan debt and you all
know it each and every one of you that
has settled the debt that you can't pay
back as you're living paycheck to
paycheck we will get it done we will
pass the pass the Bill blah blah blah
you gotta vote for Democrat down ticket
what's Trump going to say
well you would look at what they're
doing so if I owe Joe Biden 10 grand in
debt he's like you can't pay that back
so what I'm going to do is print money
and then take it from you and pay me
back sooner right I'm like dude you
can't force me to pay you back Joe Biden
and you so no
no let me pay you back at my Pace I
think which is not which is a zero
because I have no interest in paying it
back but I think the libertarian
response is going to be let the system
crumble just let it fall apart and then
we'll just restart from where we're all
about with putting the the default on
the loaners whoever loaned the money
you're not getting it back I'm not all
about printing up money to pay back
those loaners but the problem is the
loaner is the government so they got to
take the default I mean what's the point
anyway it's like a trillion bucks what's
the difference I mean I would love to
have one presidential candidate say when
I'm in office I'm going to stop issuing
student loans right because the system
is broken we can see it we haven't dealt
with the Fallout yet but no one is
saying that like why can't we just stop
a terrible program from existing I gotta
I gotta read this super chat from sunny
summer Summoner uh what's it say Sumner
Robinson Citibank has a total of is that
uh 14 trillion no 14 billion 15
basically about 15 billion that's like
the trillion doesn't mean oh no no I see
right here 15 billion shorting the
NASDAQ and the 7 billion showing the s p
Bank of America has 23 is that billion
showing the NASDAQ and 18 billion
shorting the s p
reminds me of The Big Short when uh the
guys who bet against that the housing
market were wondering why their credit
default swaps were stable as
delinquencies were skyrocketing and the
mortgages were becoming worthless it's
because the banks were lying about what
was going on so they could offload their
exposure to unsuspecting smaller Banks
and and lenders or individuals so they
would go and say hey this is worth a lot
of money you should buy it then they
would then as soon as they offloaded all
their debt they went markets exploding
have a nice day and nobody goes to jail
for it and uh at the end of The Big
Short remember they they said they've
had a little joke and you're like oh we
totally held people accountable just
kidding no we didn't so my question to
you guys is regarding the current
situation the current economy and
student loans should anyone be arrested
and if so who should people be held
accountable what should happen I know
you guys kind of started talking about
with the defaulters or or I don't know
about arrest but what I will say is if
you actually want to solve a problem you
first you identify what's causing the
problem
and I don't see that part I see people
are going straight to the problem and
trying to Band-Aid it but ultimately
they're not stopping you know the
bleeding from the wound the the biggest
issue that I see is that the federal
government is trying to play uh
manufacturing middle class
right so that's why they're they're
throwing all this money anybody can get
a student loan that's when you start
seeing for-profit colleges that don't
care about anything whereas our parents
days they got accepted into school that
was the only way you got a college
education right so the other some sort
of Merit base and then on top of that
they had to find some sort of way to get
a loan but back then it was reasonable
now it's become an entire economy on its
own based off of cheap money from the
government but with because it's no
regard they'll just give it to anybody
that's part of the problem same thing
with the 2008 crash ultimately it
stemmed from the federal government
trying to manufacture uh the middle
class by saying the American dream is to
own a home so we're going to make it
easier for everybody and what do they do
they messed up the market and they they
incentivized chaos and that's what we're
seeing with the student loan market and
they're not going to punish the people
who are actually Abu using it right the
colleges no one's talking about the
colleges everything's about what's Joe
Biden going to do no one's ever talked
about the colleges no one ever talks
about the endowment right no no what is
the endowment what's the endowment yeah
I hear that sees the endowments what is
the endowment exactly it's basically how
much money they just got sitting in
reserves right so even just money that's
been left to them or given to them yeah
okay tax-free stuff people are donating
people are donating getting a tax credit
and then that generates money off of it
does the government give them endowment
money as well I don't I don't believe so
okay I don't believe so but even even
from the fact that let's say you have a
college that has
um you know 500 million dollars I don't
know I'm just making up a number but
they're still charging your kid twenty
thousand dollars a semester right does
that seem like it makes a whole lot of
sense why is it so expensive not saying
it should be free but why is it so
expensive and on top of that you know I
was talking to Shane Cashman he was an
Adjunct professor they don't pay any
anything for these people and they hire
a whole bunch of adjunct professors so
I'm I mean they're it's a scam it's one
big scam and now they're saying let's
bail out everybody keep the system in
place and guess what in 10 to 15 years
we'll be back at the same point yeah it
seems like the college system is
decrepit at this point and that you can
educate yourself online and learn faster
more readily and from home but are the
salaries of the presidents of College's
public generally speaking I don't know
off the top of my head I think so I'm
curious to see how much money upper
management is making at these schools
because I had no idea about the drunk
Professor Thing 2 million easy yeah that
uh president of Yale makes 1.9 million a
year and remember there's like the adjun
professors but then they hire crazy
administrative blow right there was a
administrator and a sub-administrator
and someone who helps with the paperwork
and whatever else all the way down so if
the point of the institution is to have
you know professors that are researching
and studying things that they're good
Educators why are they not the priority
why do we have 85 administrators for
everyone professor so that's not the
actual statistic I'm making that up but
they're never they're never incentivized
to cut the fat yeah right there they
operate very soon with how the
government operates they create a job
and that job never goes away right so so
if the government said we will only give
money but only up to a certain amount
and they started doing that wide scale
they'd have no choice but to cut the
costs otherwise they have no customer
right so then what do they do they start
cutting the fat we can't have five
administrators
for for this task we have to reduce it
because we can't afford this if we're
going to keep everybody making about the
same amount so we have to start cutting
the fat no one ever does that when it
comes to college debt they always say
what's the federal government going to
do for us they're the ones who screwed
this all up in the first place and
that's by giving unlimited loans yeah I
mean quite literally
you can't default on it but anybody can
get it were they like trying to catch
catch up with the college's raising
costs so they would give more low they'd
be like oh we'll cover it we'll cover it
I've always heard the inverse that
colleges raise costs because basically
they were guaranteed that you would have
be able to pay tuition instead of being
like well what can the average family or
the average individual reasonably pay to
attend our school they were like well
you just take out a loan right like even
now I don't know if your son will end up
if he's not applied to college yet right
no no okay so some colleges will send
you like the acceptance letter I
remember this happening to me and
they'll be like congratulations you got
a scholarship That's so exciting except
half of your scholarship is a loan so
they're presenting it to you like wow we
want really want you to come here but
actually what they want is for you to
take out a loan to go there which is
what everyone wants you to do anyways
that's also what the federal government
wants you to do one time we talked about
on the show like I don't Advocate that
you give to your University but if you
were to why can't you give directly to a
student who is trying to pay off their
student loans why can't you cover a
portion of tuition instead of it going
into a pool more than the 800
administrators they have decide who gets
it later why can't you have a more
direct contact with the student because
again ultimately a lot of the money goes
into the endowment which never really
reaches the people who need it like the
program heads like the adjunct
professors like the students well back
to what Tim said it's a scam it's not
really about the students right they
give them a superficial product to make
them feel like they're learning right we
go and take these useless classes to
make us feel like we're pro we're being
educated right but they leave and I've
talked to so many college graduates
where I'm like I don't know what I
learned
right so you spent four years in college
you came out learning what but you owe
all this money you got scams son like I
don't know I don't know any other way to
put it what if we had like a patreon
thing for online college I know Jordan
Peterson's working on setting up an
online college and there's like Phoenix
University which was kind of a
predecessor I don't know how that works
exactly but like if you could watch the
individual students learning and you're
like I love that guy I love how fast
he's learning I want to give him 10
bucks a month just like that for a cup
of coffee a day you can but like not not
the students the professors oh yeah you
can run the professors too that'd be
awesome but that's how you do it so what
you do is you create an online
university that gets accredited that
issues degrees and then you say here are
all the professors and all the subjects
we have available and when you enroll in
one of these classes you are paying
monthly to that Professor the professor
like five percent goes to the university
or 10 like whatever like like 10 makes
sense because there's like transactional
fees and then server fees but it's
basically a patreon for Education yeah
and then when you complete the course
you'll get a degree from the University
but for me who's not even at the school
I just get to watch them learn online
the kids and they don't have money some
of them so I want to fund them to go to
college like I'm like in my 40s I'm done
with that I just got money lying
around I want a fun I'm just saying I I
personally am not in that state yet but
uh there's always something to do with
your money
um but I would like to I would like to
help fund kids without making them take
loans out well those are called
scholarships yeah so to be like a
proactive scholarship where like you're
saying you can give money like an
endowment directly to the student yeah I
wish I wish there was a scholarship that
isn't administrated by the the
university that's gonna say right there
private scholarships there's tons of
them yeah where you get to pick who gets
it yeah there's like private there's not
privates and Foundations and grants and
there are foundations that will be like
we give uh a grant to Asian Americans
who are low income and want to go to
college and then they they contact the
institution they fill out paperwork and
they say write us an SNY we should give
you the money and if you get approved we
pay for your account yeah but I guess I
would like to cut out the middleman
where it's like if I had money I could
give it directly to a student at a
school you know what I mean instead of
it going to an administrator at a
non-profit or at a school who then
decides who gets it later build the
technology call it the scholarship it'd
be interesting I I mean one of the the
challenges is that education is great
and I think people feel starved for that
in a way and I wish we had more
decentralized way I mean YouTube is the
great example right everyone always says
you can look up anything on YouTube you
can learn so much and that's amazing I
wish that like it would be cool if
cities had like more I mean public
libraries do the same stuff it's it's
just we default to thinking the
university is what's providing the
lecturers or the the things that you can
go to just to learn and I think that's
where we kind of get this like shopping
mall effect with uh with with
universities we think that's sort of
where you go like after you finish high
school you go there and you get all the
skills you need and then you leave and
it's all kind of centrally located but
really you know if you're actively
interested in a subject you have to be
more proactive the university isn't
going to really educate you on a lot of
things especially we've talked about
this for when you come out of high
school not knowing how to pay your taxes
and things like that like there are
skills that you just continue to put off
and then finally you're like what 20 to
23 getting out of college and maybe you
learn something but also you don't have
any practical skills right and I think I
think part of the problem I think is
Americans have
have caved into thinking that education
is is institutionalized like that's the
only way that you can learn so this
means the only way you can learn is by
going to a public school the only way
that you can have a real education if
you go to a college or university that's
the only way outside of that you're part
of the what non-educated class right
meanwhile these people who spend God
knows how much money you spend how many
years within School come out knowing
nothing
and making less and like it's everything
is is the inverse and it doesn't make
any sense I think we are starting to get
back and I'm trying to do this as a
parent to tell my son that intellect is
not necessarily what the teacher
you know puts on your grade intellect is
far more than that
um and so like is about learning on your
own being curious going out in the world
experiencing things having a job dealing
with people right and how you react to
how you react to the world around you in
that way like for example I'm a writer
today I didn't go to school for writing
I figured that out I figured out how to
do all these things by myself no one had
to teach me I just asked questions I
analyze things all that takes intellect
all that takes curiosity but someone
would say I'm not a real writer because
I didn't go to a school to get this to
get disagree I don't need all that I
don't have a college degree at all and
and some people are surprised that by
that because they think that I'm very
intellectual in some regard
credentialism it's credentialism they
think that if you don't have high school
diploma you must be stupid right exactly
and then they wonder why they're broke
and in debt and is it like there's
there's the pro athletes tons of pro
athletes especially in skateboarding
easy example tons of them quit quit High
School the GoPro skateboarding and other
millionaires not all of them but they're
the uh college graduate was it PhD
billionaires typically have less than
College Dropout billionaires yeah and
then you look at like Mark Zuckerberg
and I think even Bill Gates too right
dropped out no actually no Bill Gates
maybe not I'm not sure it was uh uh uh
Steve Jobs yeah yeah Steve Jobs is a
College Dropout I barely graduated high
school I didn't even walk with my class
wow you know and yeah I just stopped
going
I almost dropped at 14.
I was very close I was like three and a
half years in and I want I was so done
with it it was just like what is the
point of this they're gonna give me some
paperwork that no one's gonna ever look
at anyway and the whole idea when I was
going in was like well once you get that
degree it's going to help you get the
job like the temp job where I'm typing
on a computer that I don't want to be
doing anyway right and they never asked
and I would put on my resume no one ever
asked for 15 years no one even mentioned
a college degree they're like what's
your work experience that's all they
cared about there's a story on fortune
that says that Bill Gates dropped out of
high school during a sophomore year but
then ultimately did attend Harvard so I
don't know where he falls into this
spectrum but kind of interesting well I
love that you point out the difference
between intelligence and knowledge
they're completely different you can be
brilliant and not know anything and
wisdom yeah for sure wisdom intelligence
knowledge experience very different
things like knowledge is the stuff that
you learn and that can be learned in
lots of different ways and there are
more I know I know some dumb people who
know a lot exactly and there's some
brilliant people that don't know
anything because they just weren't
around the information to learn it like
I've met some dumb people in my days who
can like cite tons of information from
books like encyclopedic like in
knowledge but they can't put two and two
together those people are dangerous when
they get into positions of power yeah
they can tell you like who the 17th
president was when they got inaugurated
they had all this knowledge and they
can't explain the basics of like a
logical problem or anything like that
but you know and then I know people who
are really really fast can solve any
problem you give them a Rubik's Cube
they're like oh I can figure this out
real quick and you're like wow there
that's that's an intelligent person and
then there are people who are wise and
uh they say knowledge is knowing that a
tomato is a fruit and wisdom is knowing
not to put it in a fruit salad
yeah the application of knowledge you're
right and Intelligence being different
because you can say intelligence is your
comprehensive abilities not your
understanding of application of
knowledge necessarily like someone who's
intelligent can solve a puzzle very very
quickly but might put a tomato in a
tomato in a fruit salad because they've
not yet experienced it and don't
understand and someone that's wise might
be like I don't have the time for this
right now because I've got some other
things that are more important yeah I
always felt like school was about how
much you can remember yeah and put down
on the test yeah yes that's exactly what
it was and I read this really great
article that said College uh no one
should go to college unless you're
unless you're IQ tested at 110 or above
old articles probably from 20 years ago
and the argument was that schools are
basically memory centers they try to get
you to remember things but they don't
teach you what the things mean so you so
what ends up happening is young people
will gain knowledge without
understanding they'll then jumble these
ideas up in their minds in confusing
ways because they know things but they
don't understand things then they go to
college and experience the same thing
where many of these ideas are beyond the
average person but we're trying to get
average people to go to colleges you end
up with people settled with that and
unhappy and not be able to find work
yeah
all right well that being said we'll go
to super chats before we get started
with the Super Chat smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member members only shows coming up in
about a half an hour it's going to be
fun uncensored we got a story about
Communists and Elon Musk we'll talk
about it and also the Tim Cast app is
now available for download in the Google
Play Store so go download it even if you
don't want to listen to the show through
the app or whatever because you like
watching live on YouTube uh the app
still has articles and a bunch of other
cool stuff so you should download it and
check it out we're really excited it
will be up on Apple shortly it is still
going through the review process but
also you can get the tickets for the
timcast Miami event let's read
I'm not your buddy guy says dude kind of
looks like Kanye
since the beginning of the show they've
been saying oh my God I knew it so I
just so you know I I recently lost UH 60
pounds oh well I'm at 59 pounds
technically we can round up it's cool
yeah yeah
um so when I first started marketing
myself everybody said chubby Kanye
and so I I freaking knew it that someone
was gonna say that I was waiting for it
a lot of them yeah a lot of them the
thumbnail looks a lot like yeah it's
awesome waffle Sensei says is faster
than I'm not your buddy you tried but
you didn't get it sorry
all right Noah Sanders says hate that
I'm Gonna Miss This show tonight I'll be
busy working in my truck just want to
shout out the Discord community and the
Miami show we're all psyched for you all
have a blessed night thanks Noah yeah
we're actually potentially planning some
kind of VIP event because we're talking
about like an elite members thing but we
might open it up to non-elite mem like
well we're trying to figure it out I
don't want to say too much until I can
finalize everything with the people
actually doing the work to organize it
because I could just look at all Angry
if I'm like telling people things that
we haven't finalized yet but we want to
do like some kind of VIP scenario so we
want to do an elite an elite members
meet up and then some kind of VIP thing
but we'll figure it out
Bonk Bonk says we need a cast Brew
Coffee House in Herkimer County New York
lots of based people here and it's the
birthplace of Remington Arms keep it the
good work cool uh yeah we just got to
figure out how to start the franchise I
mean the first thing is we have to get
the first location open and uh hopefully
that will be within the next two months
maybe three months it was supposed to be
earlier in the year but uh the issue is
our building is a historic building and
we're trying to like you got to respect
a historic building we have like an
elevator from like the 1900s like one of
the first elevators ever put in a
building so it's super old and that
gives us issues does it work yeah oh
that's awesome but um we're not allowed
to let the public go on it
it is cool that people want to franchise
a business that isn't open yet yeah I
know I think that's a that's a good uh I
don't know a good time for the community
there's no reason you have to have a
brick and mortar there to start
franchise no I think Subway didn't have
one but I'm I'm not doing this because
it's like oh boy here's an opportunity
to get people to sell it like to buy
something no we want to have a coffee
house we want to start doing it and then
be like okay who else wants to I don't
want to just and it feels weird I'm not
interested but uh I am excited by the
idea I think we have so much interest
it's entirely possible that within like
two years there could be a hundred
locations yeah that's all independently
owned and operated and I'm thinking
about the Chick-fil-A method of like you
can only own one location because we
don't want I don't want some Corporation
with investors to be like let's purchase
50 locations and then you get this weird
corporate machine I hate I don't like
that you know I want it to be like a
individually owned and operated small
business but the brand lends people like
benefits yeah that people will find it
on Google Maps easier they'll search the
website and find your location you'll
get you know methodologies set by us and
assistants and things like that I wanted
to you know I want it to be more
communal Community stuff that's cool
hopefully but uh we are looking to hire
someone now to begin the process of
creating the system before we even
launch and then it's possible that
before it opens we could even have
people getting the ball rolling and
opening their location where can people
reach out if they're interested to get
involved with you okay I've seen a few
chats over the last couple weeks asking
about the coffee thing I never know what
to say maybe they should follow the
Casper coffee Twitter really yeah yes
follow what's the Twitter account cash
brew coffee I think it's cat yeah Casper
coffee I'll double check right now and
if anybody wants to hit me in slack with
the data of where people can contact uh
if they want to sign up to work with
Casper coffee let me know because it is
at cast Brew Coffee on Twitter follow
them and uh they're the ones running
everything and you can they can give you
more information also if you go to
castbrew.com
uh there's a contact button at the time
oh sweet oh there is yeah well look at
that
it's like it's a real business yeah
we're uh we're we're branching out we're
expanding right
we'll grab some more Super chats what do
we got
Bocephus says I'm still thinking of
moving to New Hampshire but then the
Republican Scanlon is trying to get
Trump off the ballot and to quote Tim
Florida has apocalyptic weather where's
my freedom and liberty yeah and I'll
tell you that's the thing about West
Virginia is it's it's it's really great
um but man it's it's got red tape West
Virginia's got red tape understatement
it's the Takeover it's the people here
are pushing back uh and it's and it's
really exciting I mean the the people up
in Martinsburg have been coming and
talking to us who are super excited for
the projects we're doing uh it's this is
gonna be great it's gonna be a lot of
fun we got some really cool stuff
happening up in Martinsburg and I hope
to see you all there it's a good
opportunity a lot of uh generational
businesses man yeah number one fastest
growing city in West Virginia
Martinsburg no for real yeah it is wow
and Winchester which is just south is
one of the fastest I think it is the
fastest growing city in Virginia wow
that was at least a year ago when I read
that article but yeah it's I mean well
the concern I love it here so don't come
and buy up all the housing well there's
no way we want people because the
concern that I'm hearing is that woke
people are starting to come in and
they're disrupting the local laws
they're disrupting the culture and
they're acting like they're the victims
when it happens yeah they're they're
like weird stuff going on with like that
you know what Martinsburg had a drag
show for kids yeah and I'm like how is
this happening in West Virginia in
Berkeley County well it's because the
people who live here don't understand
what's going on and we need we need
people to come and help reinforce that
culture and be like no no we're not
we're not going to do that here all
right we'll read some more
let's grab another Super Chat
says there's a video floating around of
employees of an Ace Hardware in Seattle
threatening customers with a bat and
then eventually a fight broke out all
because the customers didn't want to
wear a mask I think it's an old video
though isn't it
I haven't seen it floating around I saw
the video yeah I saw the video I can't
verify if that's actually I think it's
old yeah
yeah that happens often
oh sorry
all right let's grab another Super Chat
Zachary rossfeld says I know you don't
read these but Joe Biggs isn't given
those years to scare others they want
proud boys angry think about what
they'll do next perhaps that's it
perhaps what they're trying to do is
incite a violent reaction so they can
justify heavy-handed violence against
Trump supporters that's why I keep
saying like make money protect your
family and here and here's the really
really simple thing here's the really
simple thing
do not do what Joe Biggs did you know
why they separated him from his daughter
and they and they're laughing as they do
it yeah yeah don't let them take you
from your kids so that they can bring
your kid to some adult drag some kid
drag show or something because you know
this is their goal to take fathers away
from the family to break up families so
right now what needs to happen is ballot
harvesting and politics imagine this the
Democrats are wiggling their fingers in
your face and I'm not touching you I'm
not touching I'm not touching you and
the moment you do anything the cops jump
in and arrest you but if you stand there
and smile smugly and say I think you're
doing this because you know you're going
to lose next year and they're gonna
start crying
you just got to make sure that everyone
is handling things peacefully
peacefully that's the way to do it
because I think Trump has a really
strong chance to win now of course there
we have some paper chats I'll probably
get to in a second where people are like
yes but we'll talk about we'll talk
about it
Heron gaming news has Tim can you please
add cast Brew Coffee CBC I like that to
the links in the description also I'm
trying rise with Roberto JR this time
rip Roberto Roberto Jr Roberto is still
out there he's doing his Roberto thing
we got to keep them separate from the
ladies though because a lot of them are
his daughters and we do not want him you
know banging his daughters so he's uh
he's he's got his own little little
house
but uh we have identified Roberto III
I love you yeah he's got he's uh he's
got a white body but he's got the
Roberto head and tail and so he's
Roberto the Third how many boys were
there in the end to choose from I think
Roberto Jr had three sons well so
there's one that looks really cool
Roberto Jr apparently knocked up one of
the Jersey Giants I guess who then had a
kid and it's it's like yeah it's gonna
be big it's gonna be very very big big
rooster yeah they can get super big yeah
for those who don't know as you can
probably guess by the name Jersey Giants
are large large chickens they are I mean
you have to use like two arms to hold
very big they're very big well I mean
the ones we have aren't that big even
compared to the other ones though
they're big yeah yeah they definitely
stand out as in a side on Casper is
there any plans to start selling merch
because I want a cast brew coffee mug
and I've wanted one for all the
commercials that I've been working on
too yeah sweet at Casper coffee and ask
them I did I mentioned it to Sarah
before I'm going to push that forward
yeah all of these things are available
now headbands oh
do we have merch on the web it's not on
the website and we're we're really
really excited because um political
season kicking off means that uh they've
already started their psychotic ad buys
and so I just love it you know when we
had Michael Bloomberg advertising on on
my channel who's advertising on my
channels and it's like my ad revenues
through the roof and people are
commenting on the video like this video
where you insult Michael Bloomberg was
sponsored by Michael Bloomberg and I'm
like that's bad that's great thank you
Michael Bloomberg no but look like he he
wants to be in front of these videos
that'll exist no matter what if he
doesn't advertise my video comes out
either way so in his mind he's like I
gotta get a commercial on that video to
give a positive message before the
negative one and so he ends up paying me
to actually make the negative one
inadvertently I love it I'm excited for
all the Democrat and Republican ads that
will appear on all of our channels which
we will use to engage in culture
building did you know that Bloomberg was
doing uh multi-language advice really my
old I mean the Spanish language Tim cast
Espanol oh my God my old job I work with
like 98 Hispanic people and I went into
one of the offices and I'm just they're
listening to Spanish radio station and
then all of a sudden they're here
Michael Bloomberg and I was like he's
taking our advice it's covering all his
faces yeah he was just flooding the
market with money and if we can get AI
to do a translation I want to take the
commercial that we did and dub it and
have it in Spanish so I mean it'll be
really cool we'll get to the point where
the the voice to text translation is
better I do not believe voice to text
can uh accurately transcribe this whole
show I was uh I did a I did a video
talking about Florida and I said Ron
DeSantis and the caption said Rhonda
Santos and I'm like is that where that
came from where they were calling him
Ronda or whatever that's been calling
him Ronda since the beginning who's this
Ronda guy Rhonda Santos so it's like
yeah we're not quite there but it would
be really really cool sounds like a
Cuban neighbor in Florida I mean if you
think about it we're really close we're
we're we've already had this for 10
years with Google Google Glass where you
could say Okay Google translate oh I
just triggered everyone's devices but
then someone would speak and then you'd
see what they said and it would speak it
to you but there's still a delay between
they speak process you hear we're
getting really close to the idea of a
universal translator where you're
wearing a headphone and you just hear
your native language as they speak their
native my Google just try to translate
what you were saying dude talk about
when he's like initiate order 51 like
dude someone could come on a TV show and
say Alexa play
thousands of Wayne sorry guys it's a
great band I got one and what's wrong
it's still legal for me to do that
Google okay Google
[Laughter]
Okay Google remind me Monday through
Friday at 8pm Tim cast IRL
boom did it work done it did it I think
so
there you go everybody now you'll never
forget isn't that Insidious though how
that could be manipulated like these
these ads are getting more and more
powerful the commands they can receive
like maybe they should be yeah only know
your voice terrifying and I don't like
that you can do it over the internet
all right well what you really want to
hear is uh here's one wait wait Alexa
remind me Monday through Friday at 8pm
watch timcast IRL oh my God my wife is
freaking out
I wonder if our viewers people are like
I can't I can't it's who's who does
walls that band uh
uh who did uh
it's a band that I'm gonna tell
everyone's Alexa to play everyone's
Calling You Kanye yes I saw Kanye East
and I thought that was really fun
oh that's a good one
uh Henry back to play says ask Amazon's
I'm not gonna say the name but you get
it the the lady who will win the 2024
election
why does it say something funny
I don't we don't have one I think we
have one is sending stop setting off my
Alexa
dude you just said you said I'm sorry
I'm not supposed to say it so it's
basically change your machine like greet
it it'd be like nope not with that no
okay I don't have one and I like have
refuses to work in offices that have
them in the past like it only freaks me
out it's almost like the word Alexa is a
password and you should change that word
so your machine responds to a different
terms not for real for real you can
actually you can actually have it
respond to a computer
that's terrifying make your own weird
words so that people can't trigger it I
don't think so I think consider getting
rid of the words I think it has its name
computer and like one other things now
you can name it anything in the Alexa
app you can use you can make a device I
know but you can anyway I'm pretty sure
the weight command is is it could be
anything just not sure Alexa I've done
it you can do anything any name you type
in there
um but it works best on the first name
the original because how many people
have said the name and have talked to
the machine has all this data yeah we
got to get Casper coffee on Amazon so
that we can
you know we can say yeah
some ads during Alexa play Walls by
Kings of Leon no it's the best album
dude it's one of the best albums of the
day yeah but now people are going to be
trying to listen All right you guys I'm
not going to do that anymore
all right we'll grab some more here we
go what do we got here what do we got
here the Sig P220 says this code is can
issue a writ of mandamus the U.S Marshal
Service enforces their ruling will they
not with a threat of packing America the
idea died with reconstruction Civil War
is a power grab interesting
Admar says with biggs's sentence I got
the same pit in my stomach as when I
read about Ross Albrecht in his sentence
hit harder having a one-year-old
daughter
yeah both of the men reels and bigs have
young children and I think that's just
incredibly sad also I think biggs's
daughter is living with his
from what I know very ill mother so he's
a male support system that's been
completely removed from that family wow
we have another Casper commercial coming
out soon oh yeah I saw it today and
they're all going to be each commercial
is going to be part of a what can
effectively be turned into a movie yeah
like with portals I was thinking my guy
could travel through like Dimensions or
something well I don't think we need to
do that the The Arc so far is just that
Ian is an acolyte of Roberto
and that's it and he's trying to trick
people in drinking the coffee which
converts them you'll love the new one
yeah the special effects are fantastic
all right
we'll grab another one
Matt speaks says question for the group
if Trump wins will Kamala certify the
election no no that's okay when she
doesn't do it you know of course she's
gonna be like I'm not reading this
and then that's it and then they're
gonna be like oh Insurrection and
democrat's gonna be like yeah but who
cares we're the only ones who actually
abuse law enforcement
and Republicans are gonna be like well I
guess you're right okay back to the way
things work sure I just imagined she
would not certify it as she's cackling
at the same time I was certified
we didn't show
it was a debate
[Laughter]
Auntie C says the U.S is described in
Ezekiel 16 49-50 if those verses don't
describe the state of our nation nothing
does God help us okay well let me what
did they say was is uh let me pull this
up
Ezekiel
16 49 and what is this what is this a
reference to it's probably something
gross huh uh let's see now this was the
sin of your sister Sodom ah Sodom and
Gomorrah okay
over she and her daughters were arrogant
overfed and unconcerned they did not
help the poor and needy yep
you know there's going to be like a a
new New Testament later on and it's just
like the nation of the United States was
full of fat lazy people who didn't care
for responsibility
and their culture burned to the ground
dude it's the fentanyl thing man and
they're lacing fentanyl with this drug
that the DEA is attempting to put on a
schedule one the stuff they're lacing
with and they're moving uh marijuana
with this one through Biden proposed it
to uh Department of Health and Human
Services who accepted it who sent it to
the de-8 to move marijuana from schedule
one to schedule three so it can now
become researched yeah and uh they were
talking Matt Gates and the head of the
DEA were going back and forth about how
how horrific the opiate the opioid
crisis is these synthetic opiates are
called opioids and that marijuana can
help people get off of it they can help
their withdrawals they can help the the
pain and stuff they've known this for so
long though yeah but we're finally
moving it like we got a president that's
like
Man Hunter smoked so much I was thinking
of Biden talking about 100 dude he
smokes that so much of that junk anyway
all right Jeremy B says Hannah Claire
please assume the two-handed Tiffany
Gomez pose and say that MFR is not real
I don't know what the Direction She's
pointing it
it's like in two directions let's not
think about this when I got dressed this
morning at all
no woman could ever wear that shirt ever
again I know I also put my hair up it
was down earlier serious Gomez Vibes oh
my God I didn't realize what an
influencer she was like maybe she is a
fashion Airline whatever yeah that's the
uh that's the note that you guys saw at
the beginning of the show I was letting
Hannah Claire know you guys see the
painting that I got no the painting
where she's pointing at the plane and
everyone in the seats are fictional
people oh you got it did you like did it
arrive I remember yeah it's downstairs I
don't know where they put it but it's
like bigfoots in the back and then
there's like a Jackalope and Avril
Lavigne
awesome yeah that's great
Michael McCord says graduated in 08 with
three degrees comp sign math and theater
took a minimum of 21 plus hours worth of
courses per semester plus summer courses
graduated in 4.5 years with 3.75 GPA
while working two jobs and in a show
every semester but they get free money
dude that's badass man that's a nice
resume
tell me you're doing something amazing
with your life right now
I hope yeah you got the drive congrats
on all your hard work that's awesome
I'm sorry that the government is so bad
at this copper Lobo says Tim I've told
you time and time again the plan is to
agitate the right they want civil unrest
so they can use it as a tool to abolish
2A once 2A is gone our freedom is gone
forever I think it's a bit more uh it's
not so direct as 2A the general idea is
the only legitimacy they have is when
they respond to violence if nobody gets
violence they'll have to fake it
but nobody should get violent
all right hey Merrick says Hawaii proved
malice was right cops will follow any
order up to and including murdering
children yep
that's right uh crazy stories about kids
still in the cars when the cars burned
people don't understand uh because we
had a guy call in a member who's a
firefighter and he says when the winds
are 80 miles an hour and the fire is
blowing past you and you're burning and
you can't breathe you just you go down
and so for the people that were trapped
in their cars the fire swept in so
quickly many of them didn't make it out
and those cops held them there
mm-hmm that's it
Gitch says abortion is unconstitutional
because it violates the baby's Fourth
Amendment rights you mean I think he
meant 14th
because I don't think they're searching
the baby
they're technically seizing the baby but
uh the 14th Amendment is is interesting
because it defines that no one can be
denied human rights but it also says
being born in this country but if those
are two separate Provisions then you
don't need to be born to be a citizen
there's about there's other
qualifications
all right Jason Hutchinson says
we're not a nation of laws We're a
nation of political will quote Steve
deese
bless you I couldn't do it I tried to
stop the sneeze the cities came anyway
uh we'll grab some more a good quote
from Steve deese
yeah we're not bound by our laws we're
oath oath to uphold them dalamar says we
are a republic how many times does this
need to be said each state is an
independent entity with its own laws
when did this stop being taught because
we have a federal government and the
Constitution guarantees your rights over
the states that means if you are in one
state they can't deny that you have
inalienable rights at the federal level
so the 14th Amendment for instance you
can't have Colorado determine what a
human is and then Oklahoma determine
what a human is because then you have
disagreements over who actually gets
Federal rights the federal government
has to enforce that in which case the
federal government says if a baby in the
womb is a human and has 14th Amendment
rights you can't kill it and that
changes the law in other states do you
think there's any chance that all this
abortion stuff's going to go back to the
Supreme Court yes
but uh probably but there's no answer
the the answer is supposed to be
Congress and Congress won't do anything
about it because the Democrats just need
a wedge issue and Republicans don't have
any real power right now if the
Republicans had the presidency the
Senate and uh and the house I'd imagine
they would have they would have passed
an abortion ban I don't think so I think
it's a wedge issue for both parties to
be honest with you yeah but the thing
about the Republican party is that the
insurgents actually got in with the
Democrats Like Bernie Sanders they were
kept out and then AOC is establishment
is as establishment as they come just
masquerading as like a young leftist but
with the the more the Republican Party
actually has dissidents and people who
are who are trying to vote for things so
it's possible that they went oh no oh
whoops we can't do it but this time it's
one thing in 2016 when you still had you
know like Paul Ryan and stuff that I get
that nothing's going anywhere then but
if it were to happen now I would not be
surprised I think it's more likely that
you get an abortion ban at the
Congressional level I I think once we
have artificial wombs that are like
totally functional
in use then they can outright ban
abortion in the whole country but I
weren't so far away from that I think
that's one of the only things that comes
to my mind it's like how do you solve
this issue
you know and just be done with it and
artificial booms comes to us to think
that you could ban something that's been
happening for hundreds of thousands of
years is like I I just wouldn't uh
insane in my opinion in the same
proposition to ban it outright but
anyway I don't want to div
doesn't mean it never happens like
people have been smoking pot for
eternity and then the US banned it and
it was almost entirely wiped out people
still did it still existed but for the
most part people did not oh yeah I
should say there's no way to effectively
ban it in my opinion right just
procedurally and then criminally punish
those who go against the the law
all right think on this as you are all
conflating an act against oneself versus
an act against another gambling yourself
you go to get an abortion you're acting
against your child who is a resident of
said State Ian you are wrong that is
another human being
well so if we're talking about a baby at
eight months then you have the problem
of that baby does not need to be in the
womb
right the baby like what I mean to say
is it could survive outside could
survive outside maybe stay for a little
bit right until until it is ready to be
born but what I mean to say is
if the baby can live outside there's no
reason to kill it exactly so a woman
fleeing to kill a baby that can survive
on its own is murder yeah before that
there's a question of did the woman
invite the baby in was the baby placed
there against the woman's will those are
the questions I asked those are those
are those are constitutional rights
questions and that's why I found it
interesting that Alabama had taken steps
to sort of Legally Define what if to
give a fetus a legal personhood status
uh years before we even read like the
Roe v Wade or turnover eight month old
like a like a a two week old baby after
it's born if you stop feeding it you'd
be charged with neglect homicide if it
was eight month old and it's delivered
but needs a machine to survive but it's
for profit you got to pay money to a
company's to work the machine is it
still neglect if you say no I don't want
the machine
I think at eight months the baby does
not need a machine
like a premature baby if it's still if
it's still like machine level pretty
much I'm pretty sure but so that's why I
just picked a random number but still
needs that machine is it is it neglect
to not use the machine and just let it
die but I don't think you have that
choice if the baby's born premature the
hospital tries to save it it's like it's
like saying you know you brought up
person with a gunshot went to a hospital
and said don't help them they'd be like
okay and then they and then they do it
then they charge the mother like cost
for hey we had to do this with your baby
now you owe us forty thousand dollars
and the mother's like I don't have any
money which is why I was getting the
abortion in the first place like but
like theoretically the mother could be
like I'm surrounding the rights of this
child and then the child would be
awarded the state which is complicated
in its own right but the child Wouldn't
Die
that seems like the better option to me
make little super soldiers I mean that's
the thing that's in place right now and
it's the whole uh leave your baby in a
basket at the fire department like you
can actually do that and you're not
going to be charged by with by any money
monetary amount any uh crimes and it
relieves you of the child you know
here's a good one the mcgloan code says
Ian murder is banned rape is band theft
is banned fraud is banned and all have
been happening since forever
yep
people used to kill each other all the
time then we were like okay now we're
not gonna let that happen we're going to
make that not okay
technically murder was always bad it was
just warring factions yeah we're fine
with it but uh
you know
fraud and a bunch of things that didn't
used to be illegal are legal like fraud
wasn't illegal back then you could trick
someone and they'd be like well buyer
beware
is that right caveat I'm tour yeah let
the buyer beware yeah there's still like
legal fraud you know when your buddy
when you tell your buddy what Stock's
about to pop because you're in Congress
or they work for the company that's
about to pop the stock and then you make
the BET like that's that's fraud or
that's like it's I know I get your point
though that's a good point yeah that
banning something can make it go away
all right everybody diminish we're gonna
start getting ready for that members
only show so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really do like it it really
really does help and head over to
timcast.com click join us because the
members only show will be up on the
front page or the app download now at on
in the Google Play Store should be up in
a few minutes you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Adam gonna shout anything out
yeah uh people can read my articles on
sub stack definitely go there Adam
bukomen.subsect.com and check out wrong
speak wrong speak geek.substack.com and
if you want to be heard want to submit
an article definitely send it over right
on nice well I'm really looking forward
to the after show with my friend Kanye
East and me discount plane lady uh if
you could it would be great if you could
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram uh it's my favorite news
source but I'm completely biased because
I work there uh Shane Catherine has a
really cool story up about the main
lobstering in this industry and as you
guys probably know by now I am a main
fan girl so I highly recommend reading
it if you want to follow me personally
I'm on Twitter at HC remote and on
Instagram at hannahclear.b thank you
guys so much I'm at Ian Crossland on all
social media including X where you can
follow Adam at wrong underscore speak
thank you that's it dog and uh uh Kings
of Leon great band walls is the album so
I might just been playing random songs
off the album make sure you listen to it
all the way through some of those
there's like three on there that are so
freaking good real rock and roll man
they don't use they don't twist it
around with not not worried about being
Out Of Tune it's just hardcore melodic
rock the dudes feeling it great album
and uh you guys can follow me at Kellen
PDL we're going to jump over to the
after show if you don't know what that
means go to timcast.com uh and you can
join the Discord and you will be with
like-minded individuals and if you go on
the website you can watch the show and
uh we get spicy so come check it out
alright everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out